Yeah.
Hey everybody,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by Lumosity.
Lumosity is essentially a one stop online gym for your brain and a what it is.
It's all based on the science of neuroplasticity.
And what they do is they create a program for your specific goals to try to get
your dome working better.
It only makes sense to me that the human brain works just like pretty much
everything else in the human body,
like the lungs and like,
like the,
you know what the muscles,
the more you use it,
the better it works.
And Lumosity is designed through a series of questions and a series of goals
that you set up in advance.
They cater each individual program for you,
designed to help you with your specific functions,
whether it's memory or whether it's a tension or speed flexibility,
communicating clearly thinking outside the box.
They have all these different parameters that you set.
You set them in advance and then what it creates is essentially like games.
They're fun games that you play that can increase your memory,
uh,
increase your capacity to recall and recollect.
Things.
I think those are both the same things I just had to recall and recollect.
All right,
so this time one of them's talking point is folks,
it's fucking good for your brain.
And if you go to lumosity.com,
forward slash Joe,
uh,
try and uh,
you can go to the start page,
start training button,
click that and then start playing your first game.
That's lumosity.com/joe.
Uh,
I use it,
it's fondly of apps free iPhone,
android,
um,
probably even windows phones.
They have apps in the windows phone.
What do they call those things?
They call them,
they call them apps.
So it's funny that somebody didn't like patent apps,
you know,
so you can't call them apps.
Nobody saw the shit come at folks.
Um,
they,
they can,
uh,
they can also,
um,
set it up for you so you could use it on a tablet,
iPad and now anything you want,
really anything android or,
or a apple.
So lumosity.com forward slash Joe and a go try it out.
It's fucking awesome.
We're also brought to you by stamps.com and stamps.com is a,
uh,
a company that allows you to do all the postal shit from your house.
They give you with this a off,
if you click on the microphone in the upper right hand corner and entering the
word j,
r,
e the old timey microphone,
it will take you to the stamps.com website and show you this $110 special offer
that gives you $55 in free postage,
a free digital scale and a a four week free trial.
And what they do is they allow you to print up your postal stamps and shit on
your regular home computer and then just hand them to the postman when he gets
there.
Everything's taken care of.
Now have to go to the line,
no have to wait no half to talk to the lady that doesn't want to know have to
suffer.
I'm trying to get you away from people
and you could do it,
especially with this holiday season.
Shane Smith,
go to stamps.com you don't have to do any of that bullshit.
I hate.
It's easy.
It's quick.
Uh,
Thompson Gaura and Christina Palicki use it.
I'm pretty sure Bert Kreischer uses it.
I know Brian Red band uses it.
It's an awesome way to send things through the mail.
Ladies and gentlemen,
and again,
use the code word j,
r e and the old school microphone,
the classy microphone and get that $110 bonus offer from a company that we
recommend and our friends all use.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n and I t.
Um,
if you've seen all the,
the recent hubbub about vitamins,
there's been this,
uh,
lately this,
this big thing about vitamins and about how,
uh,
vitamins are not good for you.
There was some new study that said that vitamins don't have any benefit.
That's the conclusion that,
uh,
people read when they were talking about it.
But that's,
that's not really what it said.
What it really said is that vitamins didn't work and some very specific cases,
like we're a old people were 65 years old.
We're giving vitamins and it didn't help in any significant way to prevent them
from getting cancer.
There's a few like very specific parameters.
A study shows that high dose multivitamins have no effect on the progression of
heart disease and heart attack survivors.
And then the other one was a limited,
limited evidence supports any benefit from vitamin and mineral supplementation
for the prevention of cancer or cardiovascular disease.
These are three very specific things and on top of that,
there's been a a mound of evidence and a lot of it is listed at [inaudible] dot
com forward slash blog.
Um,
we list a infectious illness prevention,
how they've been clinically and statistically proven to help prevent a lot of
different issues that people have.
There's a reason why they give it to people with scurvy.
Okay.
They found out that scurvy is caused by a lack of vitamin C.
There's a reason why a,
there was a couple recently that was tried for murder because their child died
because it didn't have enough be 12 and the mother's milk because the family was
Vegan,
like so vitamins,
look,
vitamins are legit.
There are a hundred percent legit.
Um,
they,
it's how's your body absorbing them?
The closer the vitamins are based to food,
the more easy your body's going to absorb them.
He bought,
he's not supposed to be processing these synthetic vitamins that are filled with
toxic binders and they come in this gelatinous capsule.
Your body doesn't know what the fuck that is.
It knows it's not a cheeseburger.
It knows it's not a watermelon.
It's something weird.
And so your body pisses a lot of it out at an add on it.
One of the things that we do is we don't sell any of those synthetic vitamins.
Everything we sell,
it's food based.
And that's all we ever recommend.
I don't think that you should be taking anything that is created in a lab.
If you can get the same thing that it's extracted from food.
Um,
there's an issue with some things.
I mean,
there's a reason why you take multivitamins is first of all,
most of us don't really lead a balanced diet.
So some form of supplementation.
I prefer a green,
a green supplements like Spirulina or um,
there's a lot of different live Greens that you can buy in supermarkets and you
throw those things in.
Blenders and all that stuff is the best way to get your mind your vitamins from
leafy green vegetables and fruits and things along those lines.
But it's not a bad thing to supplement outside of that.
Even with synthetic vitamins,
it's better than nothing.
It might not have statistically proven effects on preventing heart disease and
old people,
but these are from some pretty specific parameters that they're talking about.
So I think that the say case close might,
vitamins and minerals don't work,
you're wasting their money.
That stinks.
It sounds like someone's just trying to get a lot of attention for their,
their study and it sounds like it's a,
it's a really,
not just an inaccurate conclusion,
but it seems,
it seems incompetent.
It's like a,
it's an incompetent thing to say.
There's a reason why Vitamix exists in the first place.
They've been documented,
they figured out what they are.
They're not like,
it's not like a myth.
It's not like,
well this element has no effect.
Would that element does they know exactly what they are?
They extract them,
they put them in pill form.
It's just a matter of how much of it is your body absorbing.
All vitamins are not created equally.
And you should look into all the positive benefits of,
of vitamins that we've documented.
These are not our,
not our studies.
These are all peer reviewed and a pub,
Med studies.
And uh,
we've got five of them listed on a,
on a.com on a.com including,
uh,
people talking about a,
um,
uh,
an improvement in cognition,
release of some work,
stress,
mood,
infectious illness prevention,
even juvenile delinquency.
So it's not as cut and dry as we would like you to think that said,
um,
it's one of the reasons why on it doesn't sell synthetic vitamins and,
and you know,
bound up capsules that are,
a lot of times they find those hard pills in the bottom of fucking
port-a-potties cause people shit right through them.
They don't even,
they go through your body like corn because your body's like,
what does this rock you're eating?
You're not supposed to eat a rock dummy.
He switched he kale.
All right,
you're supposed to eat cucumbers,
but if you don't have any camera cucumbers,
that rock is better than nothing.
Does what I'm trying to say.
Anyway,
ladies,
gentlemen on a.com it's o,
n n I t used the code name Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Again,
we don't have any multivitamins,
but you should read this study and then also read the [inaudible] dot com blog
because,
uh,
it's,
it's a pretty fascinating and it's pretty fascinating how irresponsible it is to
just say something doesn't work when you're talking about three very specific
examples where it didn't show a statistical improvement.
Uh,
O n,
n I t use code name rogue and save yourself some money.
Shane Smith and Eddie Wong are here.
Keith music,
the Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
I barely know enough about those words that I said to put them in a sentence in.
There it goes.
That's how easy it is to get on the Internet these days.
All that shit that I would say in about vitamins,
man,
I fucking vitamins.
You fuck with them.
I take great grape seed extract.
Oh yeah.
I take methyl assist.
Do you really
love probiotic?
We had spleens so that we could eat rocks.
Rocks.
Is that for eating rocks,
bones really wigs things.
Before I thought it was just to get ruptured.
When you play football,
like a little airbag I respect to due to eat rocks.
Yeah.
Well we got lots of shifts where we used to eat lotion,
dirt.
Oh yeah.
Well it wasn't that one of the rumors of the appendix.
I'm not sure if that was ever been proven or disproven,
but the appendix a,
it originally was an Oregon for processing meat.
I think.
Then it was found to be more um,
uh,
fibrous vegetables that that was what we had the issue until we made me.
You're saying appendix,
I'm saying spleen,
maybe it's something else altogether.
Maybe we're not doctors.
We don't know what the fuck we're talking about.
Dude.
You can't be a renegade journalist world traveler.
And a doctor,
right.
There's not enough time in this world.
And Tell Him Eddie Times,
Jay Shit together,
son,
you're back from a another crazy vice world tour.
Where'd you go?
Um,
I went to a lot of places we were shooting in Louisiana.
Uh,
that doesn't sound very dangerous,
but I've been in Louisiana has a heavy story,
Louisiana's pretty gangster.
And then we went to Turkey,
Syria,
Dagestan and Greenland,
and then Dublin.
Whoa.
What'd you do in Greenland?
We were there with the Danish and Greenland Meteorological Society as they
measured how fast the ice sheets are melting and there are melting fogging
valve.
Wow.
How fast.
Very fast.
So the IPCC report just came out and we are 60 years.
So they do every five years.
They do a report that sort of has a,
uh,
you know,
a spectrum of,
best case and worst case scenario and the worst case scenario from five years
ago,
we're now 30 years ahead of wow.
Yeah.
And so this year Greenland had its first full surface melt,
so all of the ice sheet was melting and um,
highest temperatures in recorded history,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so what it,
Greenland itself holds 23 feet of sea level rise.
So if it melts,
all of it melts.
Um,
there's 27 feet higher,
so we're all going to be underwater.
Everything.
Like how deep would that take America?
Well,
so it would be,
it would be where the water is now 27 feet higher.
So it would go like the big bear we go.
Yeah.
I mean it would go,
it would go,
I don't know how high we are up here,
but we're probably somewhere on 20 feet higher and see the lawyer should have
been maybe so we would go out there and there should be some ocean water.
Yeah.
But like Shanghai New York,
Calcutta,
actually 80 of the hundred biggest cities are at sea level.
Was it you guys that did the piece on Miami about how doomed Miami is?
Maybe
did a piece with Jay to Stevens about global warming?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
we were just in the bank,
but know that Greenland's shit when I hear things like that,
and I remember I watched the inconvenient truth high and I lit Ay Ay,
I pissed my pants and I was so,
I had a nervous breakdown.
That movie is so scary when you're like eating edibles,
but it's also the type of shit that makes me feel like I don't want to have
kids,
you know?
Yeah.
But you say that,
but why are you,
how are you right now?
You okay?
I'm okay.
I think most people are okay.
I think most people are going to remain okay despite the problems of the world.
I think we're going to figure out a way for most people to remain.
Okay.
The idea of,
uh,
you know,
bringing a kid into the world.
If you're alive,
the kid could be alive and when you're dead,
the kids going to be dead too.
Everyone's going to be dead.
What if you lived in the Mel Deeves?
Would you have kids?
I mean,
well that's shit ain't does that doesn't even exist,
right?
Yeah,
they're,
they're going away.
But actually I did a piece there too,
but a Greenland is interesting because,
you know,
so anyway,
we go to Greenland,
we measured the ice,
the ice is melting,
it's very bad.
Um,
and then we sort of said,
okay,
let's get a,
a consensus scientists like a scientist who represents this sort of global
consensus of scientific thought.
And we said,
um,
uh,
what's happening?
You know,
and he said,
we have to cut admission.
This is a conservative dude.
And he's like,
we have to cut emissions by 80%.
And I said,
okay,
what if we don't cut emissions by 80% then,
you know,
global warming will continue and then the sea level rise,
we're continuing to do.
And then I said,
well,
how much of it is manmade?
100% okay?
And so we can change it.
So I,
you're,
you're right,
Joe.
We can,
there's shit we can do to change all this stuff.
But what the interesting I said is,
okay,
so,
so if we stop,
you know,
80% emissions,
how long does it continue?
And he goes,
oh,
hundreds and hundreds of years,
probably a thousand years.
And I'm like,
so global warming continues for a thousand years no matter what happens.
And,
and,
and Greenland's going to Mulligan.
Oh yeah.
Greenland's gonna melt.
That's a given it just how fast.
So we will have 27 or 24 or whatever it is,
feet of sea level rise.
It just,
is it going to be in a hundred years?
Is it going to be 50 years?
Is it going to be in 200 years?
That's the only question now.
Wow.
And so no one anticipated this up until just a few decades ago.
We didn't even know if was fucking sea level rise is so fucking crazy.
We just started burning shit and changing
the gasses that surround the planet and be like,
dude,
don't worry.
What was the shocking thing is I'm like,
how many?
Like how you know,
is it,
how much of his mammy?
Cause I'm like,
you know,
you hear all this shit about why it's a cyclical thing and it's fine.
It's nature is always done this.
And he goes,
no,
it's 100% man.
I mean,
I'm like,
yeah,
but is that like,
you know,
and he goes,
if you talk to any scientist,
a real scientist,
uh,
you know,
95% of the global scientists are like,
this is why it's happening.
And I'm like,
well,
what are the other 5%?
He goes,
they're paid by the fucking oil companies.
So what the fuck do you think they're going to say?
So,
and it's a given.
And I'm like,
why the fuck don't more people know this?
That's one thing that I don't understand.
And we also did this thing on the drought in Texas on a,
on another story.
And everybody's like,
we asked,
do you believe in global warming?
And by the way,
all the cows are dead,
the fucking,
you know,
and,
and they're like,
Nah,
that's been disproved.
That's been disproved.
And you're like,
bye.
Who?
Jesus.
Yeah.
No,
just people just pay the lie.
Like we did a fresh off the boat episode in North Dakota and we were trying to
do stories on fracking and we stayed at a man camp and this was one of the most
bugged out things I ever did.
I stated a man camp for two nights and all the strip clubs in the area had been
shut down by the police cause they had like 150 incidents of violence in these
strip clubs because these dudes are out there by themselves working like 1618
hour shifts and they don't see any women.
So all there is is fracking sites,
man camps and strip clubs and a Walmart Rove to these frack sites.
And we're shooting there and we're trying to talk to people and everyone was
super friendly,
right?
Everyone wanted to talk to us to divert us.
We would be on a fracking site of like,
look,
let me show you another site that's better.
Let me show you.
And they drive us like 10 miles away,
30 minutes out,
and then they'd stop the truck,
pull over on the side of the road and be like,
Oh,
you know that that side I was going to show you.
It's just not here man.
Hmm.
It's just not here.
You could go back and check that place you were just at.
And then we'd go back and then nobody would talk to us.
So everybody would diverse.
And it happened numerous times over three days in North Dakota.
And we ended up pulling out of that episode because we went to a steak house one
night to talk and hang out and meet the locals.
And they were like,
look man,
the politicians like the people that run this town,
no,
you're here.
But you had tried to schedule these interviews with the politicians in this town
and the people involved in the business and they told you they would do it,
but they bailed because they just wanted to get you here and then leave you out
to dry.
Like we had a interview scheduled with all these people in the town and
literally the day of we got there,
everybody canceled and everybody diverted.
Why did they want you to go and then just leave you out to dry?
Why didn't they just want to cancel?
Yeah,
I have no idea.
I,
I'm,
I'm guessing that they figured some,
I think some people wanted to talk to us and then once word got out to,
hey,
there's these guys
with cameras in the neighborhood.
It's a small town.
The man camp,
we had to get clearances and once the people that own the man camp,
what is exactly a man camp?
A man camp is literally just rows and rows of trailers on top of gravel and you
stay,
it's like if you're like my school got hit by hurricanes before and you have
classes in trailers,
people just live in tray these trailers and they split them up for like three or
four guys and it's,
it's one of the most depressing places you could ever,
I think they're wanting to get you out to the,
to the invite you out to get you to the man camps cause you're sort of
delicious,
sensitive chip.
This is a
crazy thing.
So I watched those,
a,
the documentary on a fracking,
um,
the what?
What the hell is it called?
The famous one.
They did two of them.
Yeah.
Some guy named Fox.
Right.
What is that called again?
Gasoline.
Gasoline was freaky.
Yeah.
It's really scary.
And I,
I heard the Gaslamp got debunked.
So I said,
okay,
well what's been debunked?
And then I looked at,
I was like,
God,
they're kind of nitpick and if you're calling that debunks yeah.
And then he did gasoline to,
yeah.
Like he might've been off about some of the laws and about protection.
I think he,
he misquoted some laws and statistics,
but the,
what he didn't miss quote is these fucking people who talked about these minds
being drilled.
Then all of a sudden their water lights on fire.
He that that was,
there's no misquoting there
Doug,
you're looking at it.
It's crazy.
But that's what happens is,
is you know,
you'll do something like for example,
I just said re nine is melting and then someone will come back and say there's
more ice on the ice sheet and then there ever has been before,
whatever.
And,
and,
and I bring this up in the doc that every time I do anything on the environment,
you have to be so buttoned up because everybody comes back to you with a bunch
of bullshit.
And what it is is there'll be like,
for example,
it's winter,
so there's,
you know,
there's an increase in the ice shelf and then there's summer and then the ice
shelf met mounts.
What they do is net ice melt,
right?
That's the whole key.
Is it,
the net of the year is melting and it's melting like fucking crazy.
Of course there's some happening in the winter,
but it's the net ice melt and every time you do anything on the environment,
everybody's got some fucking crazy stat against whatever.
We did this thing,
all the cows dying in Texas because of the drought and the cattle ranches can't
afford the water.
Why?
Because the water that they do have,
they're selling to the gas industry for fracking because they need water infused
with software to get it out.
So you're just like,
look,
it's what I find shocking about it is,
okay,
that's fine.
We've been doing this shit for a long time.
We say no to things,
but we all live here like the oil guys are going to fucking get fucked to.
Their kids are going to get fuck too.
Like we are shitting where we eat.
We are fucking ourselves.
And that's what I find insidious because you're just saying we're going to fuck
it up for everybody.
And by the way,
we're not just going to fuck it up.
We're going to pay hundreds of millions of dollars to say it isn't even though
we fucking know it it because it's worth doing that for the amount of profit
that they can make.
It's Ross Spang spending hundreds of millions of dollars.
It's not the biggest business.
Did you hear by the time it affects them?
Did you hear about the guy who was the top EPA climate control specialist?
It turned out that he was saying the whole time that he was actually undercover
working for the CIA,
so he didn't do his job with the EPA at all.
He told them that he worked for the CIA and that he had like secret projects and
this was his cover,
so they paid him.
He was the highest paid employee from the EPA and he was saying he worked for
the CIA,
but he didn't work for the CIA at all,
so he was just getting all this money to fuck off.
So the guy built them at a more than more than $900,000 over the course of 10
years.
This guy was just basking in cash and this was their top paid climate
specialist.
They're top paid guy was literally a complete fraud.
Well that doesn't,
that doesn't help our or shit.
Fuck,
fuck it.
Well,
it's not good at all,
but it's like these,
these are the Bozos that are watching over this thing.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Like they let this thrips right through like don't you have to have like at
least a hall pass from the CIA before they just say,
Oh,
you worked for the CIO was also that point earlier in the year with the people
that worked at the SEC.
Then went to the banks and the people that worked at banks went to the SCC and
it's like,
Yo,
who's the gatekeeper?
Like you guys are just rubbing each other off.
Well,
not only that,
it's the educational institutions that set the standards and parameters for the
business to be practiced and leave.
There are institutions and get giant cushy jobs at these,
these banks and investment houses and there was all detailed on inside job.
You see.
Brilliant.
There was a documentary on the fall.
Great piece recently.
On the 12 bipartisan senators and Congressmen congresspeople who passed the uh,
big Pharma that the health,
the,
the pharmaceutical law and of the 12 of them,
12 quit before their term was over and went to work at big Pharma and their
average salary in Congress was like 150 grand.
Their average salary,
average salary when they left with 7.5
Jesus Christ and you're just like,
oh,
that's from,
it's from the town.
I believe it's from the objective.
When they pass those laws,
making a hundred objective,
they were just counting that cash.
Just thinking about that boat,
drive it in that Porsche convertible.
Oh,
like winning American
can idle.
You know I got elected.
Yeah.
I'm going to do a couple,
a couple records,
a under contract and then I'm going to go and fucking
not only that,
the standards have been set.
It's like that's what's been done.
It's been done many,
many times,
so they look at it as an option.
Then not only that,
they look at it as the most profitable option,
which is always the one that everybody jumps.
It's perfectly fine.
We're going to become a lobbyist.
It's going to become a thing like almost like a,
like a lawyer that's trying to get a guilty client off and it's like as a,
as a law before a lobbyist,
as an educator,
it's like,
what can I get an intellectually behind and defend,
right?
How much,
how much without being objective at all and just trying to satisfy my own need
for money.
Oh my knee.
If I'm,
if I'm like a multibillion dollar a Pharma Company,
I'm going to hire the guy that wrote the law to get what I want done.
Those conversations take place.
How those conversations take place with someone?
Did they bring you in your office and go,
listen,
I'm this fucking stupid law that tells us that we can't frack.
That's dumb and that's keeping us from making money.
Fuck all those people and their blowed up drinking water.
We need to figure out how to get the fuck in there.
Come on.
They,
they fund their election campaigns on both sides and whoever wins,
I say,
Hey,
I funded your election campaign.
You want a lot more of this?
I want to tons more money.
You want to get elected again?
Boy,
you want to sign while I get elected.
Just come over and how is that legal to,
how's it legal to fucking give money to both sides?
That's crazy money whenever you want.
It's just you fucking greedy ass holes.
So it costs a lot of money to get elected.
It should,
but it's just,
it's so blatant that that's the fact that that's how the system is.
That's the actual system itself that that you know,
the people running things like,
yeah,
that makes sense.
The reason why they can do it is because we're one of the most misinformed
generations,
like the information gap between your average reader and then the people making
these laws and the people making the deals is gigantic.
Anything is because too many laws have been passed.
It's just like too much illegal like,
well for instance,
like let's say we look at the tax code,
write the tax code is thousands and thousands and thousands of pages,
like for an average citizen to go read that,
there's no way it's incomprehensible.
Right?
They just added so many pages in so many complexities so that the average
person,
you know we used to have a duty to overthrow like the social contract,
like John Locke,
you go back to the social contract,
there's a duty to challenge a government and even to the extent overthrow it
when you think that it's not doing justice to,
to the,
to the constitution or whatever your social contract is,
but now the average person really is helpless and paralyzed because let's say
you wanted to understand tech,
you can't even just go understand tax like things are so specialized.
It's like the assembly line has taken over everything.
So we may know one thing like you mean you got comma you got,
I mean I feel like we only can know so much.
There's so much to know and things have become so specialized that it's,
it's very tough to kind of strike back at the empire.
Do you think though,
that with all this like Edward Snowden type shit and all these leaks that are
coming out over and over again with these connections between politicians and
money and the,
the influence is more transparency,
more things have been exposed now than ever before.
Do you think that's going to make it more difficult to do?
No,
no.
I think everybody goes,
Yep.
I mean,
everybody knows it now.
That's the whole thing is,
is this book just came out of the town.
Everybody goes,
Yep.
Meaning they just accept it.
Yeah.
And I agree.
Look,
I think that,
you know,
you do have a,
uh,
you get the government you deserve.
You know,
and right
now we're very complacent and we're just,
all right,
well,
whatever.
We know it's fun.
Cookies.
We know.
Yeah,
we know it's fucked up.
We know it doesn't work.
We know it's corrupt.
We know that the,
by the way,
there's good luck there.
They're playing chicken with the country every fucking month saying,
well,
we're going to default now or not.
I guess we are.
No,
we're not.
Yesterday are,
you know,
the stock market's going up and down and everything.
It doesn't work.
It's broken and everyone goes,
ah,
and it's the least productive Congress we've ever had.
They've passed the least amount of bills ever in the bills that have passed or
like fluff bills.
So what else fucking vampires is sitting there sucking money out.
Well that's the other thing is how I like it.
Tax Tax,
tax,
tax tax.
And what are they doing with it?
They're just fighting their own little fucking bottles in Washington.
No lie.
I think to answer those for people like you and Shane to run,
no lie,
no lie.
Because like why not though?
No.
The answers the aliens.
Do you ever see
discussion one time when one of our drunken ones as opposed to now,
uh,
when we said,
you know,
when you run,
when they,
they get everything.
Anything you've ever done.
Do you want to talk about 3000 page tax code?
My,
everything bad I've ever done,
but 30,000 pages of Shit.
That's why like you have to be like Mitt Romney who never did anything.
And I'm like,
I don't want Mitt Romney to run the crunchy because he's done nothing wrong
cause nobody's done nothing wrong.
Everybody does bad shit everyday.
Like you know,
so having somebody you know,
well I dunno,
maybe he kills kittens.
I don't know.
But you know,
generally,
but to me that's what's abnormal.
What's abnormal is never having done anything bad.
And you're like,
that's not human.
I think everyone's bullshit's going to be exposed one day.
I think one day,
I mean it might be our kids,
the generations growing up right now,
it might be the only kids that never get to have secrets.
Whereas like we've kept secrets for the longest time and then secrets are
exposed on the Internet and that's very interesting.
There's more transparency now than ever.
I think there's going to be no secrets in the future.
I think there's a backlash against this.
No secret bullshit for sure.
Book was like no secrets,
no secrets,
because Zuckerberg never had a girlfriend.
So He's like you.
Everybody wants to know everything.
And then Evan comes along with snapchat and goes,
actually I had girlfriends and many of them,
so uh,
there is to only privacy now and so exposed.
They have an inability to hide,
but I think that's going to be going to change because these politicians
running,
if you look at like their twitters and they're following,
they don't have nearly as many people as you.
You can use social media.
I bet you could run and win.
I don't want to run and when I don't want to run anything,
I'll get,
I pay my taxes and hide.
You got to do it for the source of the top two out of the forest with other
shit.
That's the thing.
Everybody has their own path in life.
Everyone has their own path in life.
Rogan,
nation,
barely
puppet government.
If I ever did when and anybody ever did listen to me,
whether it'd be a sorry state of this world,
a person who is acknowledged to be half retarded.
I think this Shane is right man.
We deserve
the government we get and I don't think unless we get involved,
I wish kids would get involved.
You know,
it's also,
I think the entire culture is changing at a pretty rapid rate whether we realize
it or not.
I think the Internet over the last 20 years has changed
so much in such a vast degree from,
you know,
where we were as a culture then.
I think we're still in the midst of this crazy wave that's washed over us and we
haven't let everything settle down yet.
100% it's still going to,
I mean this isn't good.
I think ultimately we're going to have to figure out a way to vote online and
when we figure out a way to vote online,
a least one group is going to set up a way to have a mirror vote that doesn't
count,
but allows people to know for a fact that it hasn't been fucked with.
It's really easy to click on two sites to how I vote and then you have like
pledge to do the true vote as well.
So everybody goes to true vote.com and they set up a thing there so they know
this is not affiliated with the government,
it's not affiliated with any corporations.
It's just set up by a nonprofit to only collect votes.
Then you give everybody's Ip a very specific amount of votes.
You find out what you know,
how many people are in the household,
verify and get everyone to socials.
Get all in a fucking database,
and then let's see if the votes real.
Let's see if the digital vote is real.
If it's been fucked with and you'd count it to true vote and that way you keep
them honest.
You just have a few of these true votes,
things that are certified by whoever,
you know,
whoever,
and we figured out a way to find out what the fuck people really want.
That will change everything.
That will fucking change everything that and someone coming along and figuring
out and organized way to utilize people the same way corporations utilize their
people,
they,
there's that money's coming from people.
It's coming from people that work there that makes sure the corporation
continues to make money.
Stockholders behind that,
the people who run it,
it's all people.
If you get a gang of people that believes that you shouldn't be shitting into
the water wells of South Dakota,
north wall of these fucking places where they're fracking.
If you get everybody to put their money behind that you're,
you're talking about corporation money,
you get a bunch of people to put in five bucks,
you get a few million of those,
you got some real fucking money to play.
I also think thank
you have,
you know,
uh,
as that he was saying,
you know,
this generation is completely different than any other generation.
I want to talk about Gen y and they've come up with this,
the different and the healthy sort of disregard for the political system of the
media,
for the news,
for all these things.
They,
they get there.
They informed themselves,
as you were saying in their own way.
And I think that they're going to work outside of the system a lot and I think
they're going to use the tools that they grew up with,
which are these,
you know,
social media tools,
tools.
He's brand new tools to do shit in a way that we can't even fucking imagine.
And you're already seeing it happening.
Obviously you see it happening in other places like Arab spring and around the
world and China and Southeast Asia and China.
But like,
you know when it hits here,
it's,
it's gonna be
a fucking revolution,
I hope.
Yeah.
No,
people are going to get to a point where they realize if they don't do it,
nobody else is gonna do it for them.
Your parents definitely ain't doing that shift for you.
No,
no.
My parents' dog,
my parents,
not the Internet.
Amazing.
But the Internet is also this amazing tool to distract you from everything that
you need to do and you need to read.
Like you have the ability to,
to jerk off every five minutes if you want to.
So yeah,
I don't have that ability.
I don't know what you're saying and know that I need to get it though.
Every five minutes on your own.
You're a God damn rabbit.
Yeah.
Chinese.
We are rabbits.
Look how many people we made.
That's a good point.
That's a good point,
man.
It's a very good point actually.
But the Chinese and the Indians should have a war.
So who fucks the most?
Yeah,
we could throw a lot of milkshakes.
Indians,
I think.
Would Indians win?
Well,
they have books on it.
Right?
So the Chinese though.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
the Indians,
it's a more refined act for them.
They have,
they have a method to their madness.
Chinese just fucking,
we just fucking,
we out there.
What's so crazy now they're allowing Chinese people in China to have more than
one baby.
If they came from single baby households,
single child households,
which is kinda interesting.
Yup.
Well they have problems there because there's 50 million more men than women.
So they,
it's just,
that is crazy.
There's also ghost towns they need to fill.
There you go.
Yeah.
That's also crazy.
Did you guys cover something like that?
Vice Shane did.
I was in China for a month this summer to write my second book.
I was in Chengdu for about three weeks.
I was in Shanghai for a week and I was in Mongolia for weeks.
I was just hanging out out there to see and things.
It's pretty,
yeah.
Crazy.
What is that one town in China that's a replica of another town.
There's a lot of them.
There's Paris.
Really?
They have a replica Paris.
Nobody lives in like U Albany lives.
They're completely empty.
Completely empty.
3% occupancy.
Yeah,
three.
Yeah.
That must be the weirdest.
They have.
They have like a Scandinavia.
They have a Paris,
they have like a can of Italian themed one.
Oh my God.
They're fucking crazy.
The Paris one.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Where did these people get their food?
That was one of the best episodes on vice.
That's so fucking strange.
Yeah.
The thing is with China,
it's everything
about that country.
If you go now though is it's at that point in a civilization where the people
may be able to catch the matrix.
Like in America there's Snowden and he's great and he's this blip on the radar.
We had wiki leaks,
but as soon as there's one of those guys,
the government and the Matrix,
it adapts so much faster than the people like it can take care of that.
It can.
So I don't know about that.
The government is actually offering him,
there's this people in the NSA that are offering him immunity if he,
uh,
if he returns all the rest of his files because apparently he's was only
released 1% of the files that he took from the NSA.
Or you're saying the Chinese?
Well,
China's interesting to me.
Like I know what you're saying,
like snow students and I love Snowden.
Snowden should have one time person of the year in my opinion,
he should have fucking one person in the year.
But China,
what's interesting is there isn't this stranglehold on the local government.
The local government isn't as strong as it is in America because the tentacles
of government here are refined.
Like it really has a grip on us.
It sees everything in China.
There is a line of chaos and people can do their own thing.
Like when you go to a bank in China,
there are homies in there with just a bag of money and a calculator selling
currency at a rate below the bank.
And nobody goes into his business with the bank.
So there's a lot of this like kind of wild,
wild west economics going on out there.
I lived in a super eight motel that a girl rented like a floor of rooms out from
the super eight decorated them like on some ace hotel shit and then rented them
out to foreigners and made more money.
And then there's an office building that's a converted super eight room right
next to me.
Like there's this weird Kooky stuff going on.
There's not as much regulation and it's kind of cool to see because there is,
they don't have the freedom of Internet.
They don't have that federal freedom like we have,
but they do have this like local freedom that is very,
very interesting for me to see.
Do they have an intranet?
Like an inner Chinese nat?
Yeah,
China's kind of strategy is,
look,
there's apple everywhere.
We're going to have our own bootleg apple.
We're going to have our own way ball like bootleg Twitter.
We have our own telecom businesses,
their ideas.
We have this many people.
If we just keep the money in the country,
we're going to be fine.
So that's what they do.
They have all their own stuff.
Is it as effective?
Absolutely not.
None of it runs as well.
We know.
No crazy.
That is it.
Everything they do is a copy that's so fucking strange.
They're copying entire cities like down to the,
the stains on the marble.
Why tell Toby America creates things.
China copies things and then Japan turns them into stuffed animals.
It is weird though.
Like what is it psychologically that makes a culture be responsible for so much
duplicate?
It's probably because that's how they,
they made their money.
That's the goal.
Why,
why,
what,
what caused that?
What was the trigger that made them not,
not have anything that they're creating themselves,
that they're duplicating so many different things.
You don't need to be creative there.
Cause it's a,
it's,
it stems from a peasant culture,
peasant revolution.
People can't afford the real thing.
So as a business president,
all you have to do is create that product at the proper price point in this
civilization.
Yeah,
because it's manufacturing.
So basically you would go over there,
you would give them the IP or the technology or whatever.
And say make this thing and then they would make it,
you know,
nine to five and then five to nine they're making the number twos to send tell
sell to India or Southeast Asia or wherever else.
So that's what the whole economy is based on.
And then if you look at,
actually the interesting one is actually pcs because it was like HP,
Ibm,
Dell,
and we all manufactured them in China and then all of a sudden Lenovo and Acer
and all these companies became the big,
and it's because the factories just took the technology from like a Dell put it
out six months before Dow and then at like not for 99 bucks.
And so del couldn't compete with their own factory because they just took the
shit and sold it for much cheaper.
So they just took the design and recreated it and just didn't call it a Dell.
Correct.
It is kind of smart though.
Yeah,
it's super scary.
Smart.
Sure.
If you could just steal people's ideas.
It's smart.
Yeah,
it's in a,
I always feel this way.
If,
if people in China spent as much time trying to create something new as they do
copying,
it'd be probably in a better place.
Right.
Cause they even have like,
it's an interesting cycle.
Restaurants,
we cycle oil,
you know,
there's just so many things they do to get around.
Like Roman,
there was that fake lion in the zoo.
They put the Tibet and dog and the zoo and called it a lion.
Have you,
have you ever heard of it?
But have you heard the big,
the big story out of China and out of the fake food story?
Why?
Which one?
So you know they,
they,
they keep finding like eggs now that are totally synthetic eggs and they have
the,
the pork that they put under the thing and it's good.
It was fluorescent blue.
Yeah.
I heard.
And then they have the created week.
Like basically they have a food issue so that they've come up with and I'm like,
Whoa,
hold on.
Eggs aren't fucking expensive.
I mean you get a chicken lays eggs.
Like,
isn't it more expensive to make a fake egg out of chemicals and make a fake egg
shell and shit and so much effort,
effort to shift from a,
does it have a fake eggs?
So why are they doing it then?
Cause there's not enough eggs.
No,
nothing.
So they're making some sort of synthetic egg.
Got a what?
Chemicals.
What kind of drew?
Look it up online.
Look up,
look up a fake Chinese fake food.
There's all kinds of stories coming out now.
Yeah.
And if you just Google food safety in China,
it's horrific.
It's fat.
It's sad.
I feel bad for the Peter's better fake food scandal.
Rocks China.
Yeah.
Wow.
How to make a rotten egg thing.
I would tell people those when I read these stories,
I'm like,
don't judge the people.
They're like,
they're uninformed and they kind of in a lot of ways don't even have a chance
against this.
Like I hung out with the locals there and they're like,
look,
we know we're eating fake,
right?
We know we're eating recycled oil.
We know it's going to kill us and it's bad for us.
But like we have no choice like their government.
It's even harder to like effect on a f.
I mean,
you can't affect it on a federal level.
Prepare a mold.
They mix the right amount of resins,
starch,
coagulant and pigments to make the eggs white.
Uh,
sodium algernate extracted from brown algae gives the egg white,
the wanted viscosity.
Then they add fake egg yolk from a different mix of resin and pigments.
Once the proper shape is achieved.
And amalgamate of parafin was gypsum powder and calcium carbonate makes for a
credible shell.
It sounds like it's like $100,000.
Right?
This is fucking insane.
There's all kinds of stories.
Not today have fake eggs.
They have this crazy,
you should look up the pork one.
They have the fake wheat and the wheat is,
I believe,
actually poisonous.
Uh,
wow.
This is fun.
Says this and this is all just because they have not enough food.
Yeah.
And I think it's just,
you know,
look,
it's again,
to go back to the hell beautiful human beings are,
it's a way to make money.
You know,
you have a factory,
you figure out the shit,
you manufacture millions of these eggs at a paraffin calsl mate,
and you sell it,
including cases of pork colored to be sold as beef pork that glowed blue
recycled steam buns and a Tofu fermented with sewage.
Oh my God.
And this is just because there's just no way to sustain that kind of a pocket
layers.
There's a lion in front of the zoo.
That's a real lion,
bro.
No lie.
I was like,
Beethoven didn't get a haircut.
So stupid.
They called that a lion.
Jesus Christ.
What a weird fucking country.
And what do they do now?
I mean,
they're going to keep growing and they're going to grow with more boys than they
are girls.
So if people are going to have kids,
like how the fucker 50 million extra boy's gonna find brides or boyfriends even.
Yeah.
But if you,
if you look at China,
if you look at China though,
it's,
it's interesting because when I go to China,
go to China a lot,
I think this is what British people must've felt like when they came to America,
because you would use a tool around America.
When you're from Britain,
it's bigger,
it's got more people,
it's got all these factories where they're making tons of shit.
And then you go back to England and you're like,
well we got banking and you know,
you know when we don't,
we don't really build anything anymore.
And you could just see it coming.
And when you go to China,
they're just making shit.
They're making stuff and they're selling stuff and they're building shit,
jumping off and going crazy.
But anyway,
there,
and they're there,
whatever,
three times the size.
So you sit there and you say,
yeah,
eventually they're going to get there,
they're going to win.
And then we're going to be Great Britain sort of saying,
no,
we're going to be going around going,
well now we do banking and services and it be like England's nice place and
everything.
Well,
we're not going to be number one anymore.
The military part of our number one is the craziest part,
isn't it?
I mean,
as far as like,
well their military is much bigger,
but the thing is is we have the tech,
but they're going to have the tech soon.
Why?
Because we sell it to them.
Right.
Of course we sell it to them.
There's also that thing going on at the South China seas though.
Like definitely Japan fighting primary.
He wants to militarize like that's scary to what's going on.
Yeah.
But Japan,
that's just a bunch of posture because Japan can't fuck with anybody.
I mean like this especially,
can't fuck with China and no one could fuck with China.
Yeah.
So the South China seas,
China was telling people if you're going to fly through this zone in the south
China seas,
this is our
territory.
You're going to notify us when we fly through Japan was like,
we don't concede that that's your territory,
nor does Korea.
And an America stepped in and was like,
you know,
we feel like there needs to be some sort of compromise on this.
So it's,
it's a disputed issue right now.
I think Carrie just went over to Japan to talk to them about the issue.
But have you been to China,
Joe?
No,
it honestly is pretty cool.
You should definitely go.
The people are amazing.
The government is on some other shit.
The government is awesome.
And the business people that run that country do not give a fuck about humanity.
That's the problem isn't a case too.
I mean a,
I would assume at least that when you get that amount,
that amount of people,
that it's sort of like a big cities,
how big cities,
people are not as valuable to each other as they aren't small towns,
small towns.
People are a little bit kinder to each other because they're,
you know,
they're dealing with a one on one person on a regular basis.
Whereas in big cities,
you know,
he,
like I was talking about Jim Norton lives in Manhattan and he jokes around about
how he lives in this big box filled with people and he doesn't know anybody.
He has an apartment building he lives and he doesn't know a single one of them.
And it's like people aren't as valuable.
They're not worth as much.
I wonder if that's the case with a place like China.
It's just like when you got a billion people that's,
they're not,
it's not like a precious resource.
It's like there's a burden.
The class divide is also so crazy,
so you don't come into contact with someone of the lower class,
like the person that you're dumping those goods on you.
You never meet that person.
Like when I lived in Chengdu,
there's less of that divide.
The divide is still there,
but you meet people from all walks of life.
Even though that city is becoming one of China's largest,
those people are in touch because some of them were very poor.
They open small stores,
became lower,
lower middle class in China,
but they still remember what it was.
If you go to Shanghai,
it's like if you,
if I bring up an argument about pollution or humanity or whatever,
they're really just like,
look,
this place is going to be polluted.
People are gonna eat fake food.
People are going to be sick,
but there's nothing I can do and I'm going to get paid as much as I can until
I'm going to leave and nobody wants to raise their kids there.
Everybody knows the environment is not conducive to like raising kids is not
conducive to living and it's getting worse than life's places.
Like third instructing pilots on how to land in low visibility from Beijing.
If you spend a lot of time in Beijing,
you never see the sky.
Yeah.
Ever.
Ever Yell God damn.
How bad is after your lungs?
I'm fairly horrible.
I mean they do.
How do you feel when you leave that?
It's tough,
man.
You can tell.
You can tell even the water when you take a shower,
sometimes it leaves a little like grayness behind.
It's bad.
Like how Eddie comes on the show and we just bashed China for an hour
trying to figure out what it costs.
I just hope to like,
I mean I don't know how to do it.
I'm writing this book.
It's really hard to write the book because you want the best for these people
and the people want like the people know what they're being subjected to,
but I mean they don't have the freedom to fly around and pick up and move
somewhere else.
Sure.
I mean,
they're kind of stuck where they are and they're at the mercy of this
government,
this new,
this new pro chairman.
I forget what it's called,
president chairman,
whatever.
He's coming in,
he's doing a good job in terms of the corruption and he's taking down people at
very high levels that were never exposed to trial or inspection.
So that's good.
But you,
you,
you're just kind of skeptical as to,
is this,
is this just for a show or are you just taking down a couple people who don't
matter or are you really gonna go after this and turn this country around?
So who knows?
Sure.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean,
I love the country and I loved the people.
It's just if you go to any,
if you go to any country,
people are nice.
Yeah.
Or,
or like you go,
go to someone's house and they say,
stay in my house and you need some lamb and you fucking have a beer and they're
all fine.
But they could be at war,
but they,
you go to Afghany Afghany houses,
they're super nice.
You,
I was in Dagestan,
Everybody's super nice to you.
They want to kill you,
you know,
uh,
philosophically lower like your,
your country,
like Dagestan is basically a terrorist university,
right?
Because
they've been trying to separate from Russia for so long.
You know,
there's this war in Chechnya,
everybody came over to Dagestan.
So you have this small little country that's continually at war with the
Russians and the Russians are like sending the special forces,
the Spetsnaz down,
you know,
and,
and the Spetsnaz guys just kidnap people and cut off their heads.
And so the,
because of this happening and like the,
the young men go into the forest,
quote unquote,
which is to join the insurgency.
And there's so many of them that now they're surfacing in Syria and Afghanistan,
here in America,
the Boston bombers,
when the older one time and then went to Dagestan for six months before the
bombing.
And,
um,
uh,
Russia obviously in,
in,
in Denmark and Czech Republic,
all these Dagestani terrorists are,
are,
are sort of coming out and it,
and you know,
it's because,
you know,
they're,
they're fighting for,
for global jihad,
for Global Sharia.
Uh,
and,
and they,
they,
it's like a one way ticket to go and they literally go into the forest and learn
from the best terrorist how to be the best terrorists in the,
in the world.
And then they go around the world and,
and,
and commit their crimes.
Um,
but when I was there,
so,
so these people are,
are theoretically like,
they hate me,
you know,
cause I'm there with a camera and going,
where did the Boston bomber go?
And you know,
and so,
and so you think they would hate me,
but they're like,
come in,
you know,
fucking have lamb.
Our son was kidnapped,
you know,
my daughter became a black widow.
We want to tell you the story,
have some tea,
you know,
sit down and we want to tell you,
we want to tell you want to tell you.
But meanwhile the whole place is basically sort of on this,
you know,
civil war,
that sort of bubbling.
And because of that,
you know,
it's just like you,
all the young men are just learning how to fuck shit up and how to kill people,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Is there anything to it besides just terror?
Like when you meet these people?
I mean,
I've never met one.
I'm just curious like through your eyes,
what it's like.
Are they just like one layer?
It's incredibly simple.
We just did a thing called children of the drones.
It's fucking fascinating if I do say so myself,
but uh,
I don't know.
I'm not supposed to tell him these.
We haven't heard them yet.
But there's two things.
One was me and down there,
there was children and the drones,
what happens is you have a brother or a cousin or whatever,
your best friend,
whatever it is,
he just disappeared one day.
He's just gone.
And because of the insurgency,
the special forces can do whatever the fuck they want.
And so they just,
Oh,
you don't look right or you went to this mosque or you have a beard or I just
don't like you,
whatever the fuck it is.
And they kidnap you,
right?
And they kill you generally are torture you or whatever.
You just disappear.
So imagine when you're 19 and you're a hothead and your,
you know,
fucking want to fuck shit up whenever and your best friend or your brother or
your dad or whatever it gets kidnapped,
what the fuck are you going to do?
You're going to say,
I'm going to fucking fuck shit up.
And then there's a whole bunch of guys who are waiting for you in the forest.
Where do you go in there?
And they said,
here's a gun and I'm going to train you how to build bombs and you're going to
go fucking low.
The motherfuckers up who killed your dad.
And it's just,
it's very simple.
Like everyone talks about ideology or it's this or it's,
you know,
global tree or all this stuff.
The fact of matter is they just killed your dad.
So you're going to then,
I mean I'm going to fuck you up.
And especially in these countries where that's part of the culture.
Like if you blood on blood for blood,
same thing with children or the drones.
You know we,
we,
we became enamored with drones because there's,
our boys don't get killed and you know,
we just send them in and they fucking,
there's no collateral damage and all this stuff.
Surgical and of course it's bullshit and you know,
there's lots of collateral damage and these people know that computers are
basically killing their brothers and their sisters and their dad and their mom.
So we went to Pakistan and we're like,
why are,
why,
what the fuck are we going?
Why is everybody joining the Taliban?
He was more Taliban in Pakistan.
Then there is in fucking Afghanistan and you know,
the drones go,
they kill somebody family and then the Taliban says,
see these fucking motherfuckers are killing us by remote control.
And this one woman who runs a school to d Taliban dudes is like for every drone
attack you have a hundred new recruits to the Taliban and all of those a hundred
new recruits,
they will be suicide bombers who will go to America,
who will go to American troops and we'll fucking blow themselves up every
fucking drone attack.
And it's very simple.
You killed my dad,
I am now going to kill you.
So this imbalance in terms of warfare,
there's a yin and a Yang to life and this imbalance is causing this massive
buildup that one day is kind of slap us in the face.
We are training right now in Dagestan and in Pakistan a hundred alcaide is one.
And,
and the irony is we went into Afghanistan 11 years ago to to,
to,
to take away the basis,
you know,
to,
to get al Qaeda to get Taliban out because of they were giving sanctuary to al
Qaeda.
And now because of the process that we're doing,
we're making a hundred more al-Qaeda's.
It's it and,
and the sort of whole cyclical thing is staggering.
It's fucking bananas,
man.
That's such a crazy statistic.
If you really think about the possibility that that's true.
100 for every drawing attack and there's a lot of goddamn drone attacks and the
number of people that are killed that are civilians.
It's pretty high.
Yeah.
This,
this may sound stupid shame,
but I'm just curious,
is this for these people,
like it's purely just hate and revenge.
Like if they somehow came to power,
let's say,
like what is the objective is that it is the objective just to make other people
feel the pain that they felt from these drone attacks or,
I mean,
well there's,
there's not trying to give like credibility,
ideological stuff and there's,
and there's,
there's philosophy obviously,
but the majority of it is young men by and large.
And now in Dagestan more and more women whose families,
husbands,
wives.
I know if you fucking kidnapped my wife and killed her,
I would go ape shit.
If you kidnap my kids,
if a computer fucking model airplane killed my children,
I would blow the fucking shit up.
I would go fucking ape shit.
So it's not unnatural for them to do that.
To say I'm,
and especially if you're young and you don't have a future and you know a lot of
them are literate and are told by their rules,
you know what?
You're going to go to heaven if you blow yourself up.
You're like,
this is a good thing if you go attack these guys.
And so it's not like they're going to get in trouble.
It's not like they're going to go to jail or any of this shit because they're
going to die and then they're going to go to heaven.
So there's all that stuff.
What wrapped up into it too.
What happens when civilians are killed?
When I know,
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry.
One other thing is if you had a bunch of Taliban invade America,
you know,
with long beards and,
and,
and sort of turbans,
how many Americans would fight to the death to get those guys out?
I mean,
we've seen it.
All we would need is Texas.
But I'm just saying,
so you have that alarmed,
you have that and everyone would fight to the death.
And so you're like,
well,
that's what they're doing.
They're like,
we are.
We are in,
like we invade them and then occupied their country.
So they're just saying,
I'm going to kill you just for that,
let alone go to heaven,
let alone the fact that you killed my brother.
Wow.
And there's no,
I mean,
how do you argue against that if you killed a bunch of people that actually our
innocence,
what I was gonna say is what's the process when innocence or killed by drones?
Is there?
Apologies.
Did they get paid?
No.
And,
and the other thing that's interesting about that is,
so we interviewed the drone pilots and they were like crying and I killed people
and it fucked me up.
And then you,
we interviewed the kids and they're crying,
everybody's crying and so you're,
you're,
you know,
and,
and then,
then we interviewed Taliban kids who,
who joined the Taliban and they were like,
you know,
there has to be recompense.
You can't just fucking kill us all the fucking time.
And so they joined the Taliban and they're just,
they will fuck up anything with an American flag.
And it's,
and look,
no,
I understand.
I understand it though.
Even if you paid in,
there's recompense like,
hey,
I killed your mom,
I built you a house.
Like who the fuck's gonna live in it?
Right.
I don't think there's anything you can do.
Like the drone strikes is just actionable.
They're totally unconscionable.
But once there has been casualties and those casualties or ignored,
that almost seems like a strategy to try to fuel the enemy.
I mean it really almost seems so short sighted.
You know,
we can chalk it off to incompetence,
which is most likely that.
But if you can't look at the consequences of that in competence and see that
this is going to cause a bunch of people cheap,
then you don't have to train the pilot.
You don't have to have a big jet.
It's just a,
it's a cheap little drone that has missiles or machine going on wants.
What we see is he can common with everything we've talked about,
global warming,
fake food.
Everybody just wants to pass the bill to the next generation and the next
generation because they figured,
well I don't have to deal with these people right now.
Yeah.
Well,
and also what they don't realize is,
well fuck it,
it's in Pakistan.
They can't come get me here.
And as we've learned from al Qaeda,
they fucking cat and they will,
oh Jesus fucking Christ.
Are there answers Shane?
Well,
but I,
I look it,
the first thing is to know what the problems are.
And then once we,
this is why global warming everything at somebody.
And even by the way,
even if global warming isn't true,
which it is,
but even if it isn't,
and I,
and I say this to the climate change deniers all the time,
I'm like,
even if it's a five fucking percent chance that this is all going to fucking
fuck up and we're all going to die,
don't you want to hedge your bets rather than you saying this for sure is not
happening.
Even if there's a 1% chance,
don't you want to fucking hedge your bets just as a smart fucking person anyway.
But first of all,
you have to say what is the problem?
And by the way,
as humans,
we don't want to say what is the problem?
We have to say what is the problem?
And then you can say let's fix it.
For example,
and I don't know if I've told this story and you can stop me if I have,
but one of the most interesting things I did recently is I went to the
Zeitgeists conference,
which is the Google conference and they had this kid there who's like 18 years
old and he built the first reactor in his garage when he was like 13 and he came
up with this way of finding a like radioactive,
like it's like a Geiger counter,
but they do it with like a water is the basis of that.
So it's so big that they can do like ports.
If they were,
you know,
tankers with uh,
illegal radioactive material they could figure out out in these ports.
This kid came up with him,
he was 16,
his new technology,
uh,
that he was pitching.
And by the way my jaw was dropping is to take all the,
spent a radioactive fuel,
you know,
the shit that we can't dispose of,
its got 50,000 year shelf life.
We can only guarantee safety for a hundred years.
All the spent fuel from all our reactors.
He's got this technology that,
that he can theoretically,
and I dunno,
I,
you know,
I haven't verified this cause I'm not a nuclear physicist,
but he can take that spent fuel power his failsafe reactors that cannot whatever
be bad down to where they have no uh,
radiation left in them cause cause the,
the fuel rods,
we actually only use like 90,
sorry,
7%.
So there's 93% left in them when we,
when we put them away and that,
so he can take them down to when they're benign and,
and fuel the world for the next 20,000 years.
And I'm like,
and by the way,
I believed it,
but even if it's bullshit,
like that's the technology we should be going for.
That's the kind of shit that we should be saying.
Yes please.
Let's take all the fucking bad evil shit that we buried in the ground that we
can't even take that up.
Power these reactors and have 20,000 years of fucking energy doesn't have it.
We should pursue the exact,
how much science has been done.
I mean,
if you,
have you read any of the work that's been done to try to,
well,
so this,
he's,
he's like,
he's like the,
the,
the sort of boy phenom of,
of,
of physics.
He's backed by the like,
you know,
uh,
Bill Gates and,
and you know,
Buffett and uh,
the Google,
the Google guys,
I mean,
he's sort of like a vetted kid.
He's a famous,
you know,
brain about this stuff.
I'm pretty sure that they're not going to just say come spew bullshit to a bunch
of fucking,
you know,
old people.
But again,
I,
I have not verified it,
but this is his theory.
Someone should look them up online or figure it out or whatever.
But when I heard that,
I'm like,
again,
even if it isn't true,
that's the type of shit that we should be going for.
Because once we realize that if global warming is true,
which it is,
if we have to cut carbon emissions by 80% which we can,
then you need to have this technology which says,
okay,
all of the fuel is there.
We don't have to,
no one has to pay for energy anymore cause 20,000 years of fuel is in these
spent reactors that we don't have to pay for it.
So yeah,
but that Shit's going to get moved to run on trucks that are going to be driven
by God's on math and they're going to fucking go off the road.
That's what the gas companies are going to say.
Cause they're going to want us to take like 50 to a hundred years to institute
detection.
Yeah.
All the gas companies are going to hire drivers to be on the Mat,
make sure they crash.
They're going to give these dudes meth so they hold on a second.
Shit,
get away from your doom and gloom.
Shouldn't say yes Joe,
you're right.
We can fucking be better.
We can be better.
But it's not this way.
Traveling around with fucking truck loads of nuclear waste.
Whoa.
We'll bring the machine to the wayside.
It's not happening.
This is a mess.
This is a goddamn mess.
They're going to drive nuclear waste through the middle of America.
They're going to have trucks full of death just rolling through your town 40
miles an hour.
The already I already do.
I mean we've been doing it for 50 fucking years.
Red.
I'd skinny man whose hair is falling out like fucking fall leaves cause he's
just radiated the fuck.
Oh No.
He's radiating off and on math.
Matt,
just fucking gun in it through the main street.
Ignoring lights like a Stephen King movie.
Just see,
right.
I want to bring kids into that red eyed skinny and what the fucking hammered to
the floor.
Bye Bye.
No s'mores in the balance.
You know someone's writing this all down right now.
It's going to be a movie in six months.
I hope that it is.
I like moving truck.
Can't extremely dangerous radioactive material found after it was stolen in
Mexico.
Um,
hey,
don't they have like at least one guard?
You gotta fucking a couple of dudes with machine guns when you're carrying
around nuclear waste in the back of a truck going to Mexico.
Jesus Christ.
There was a famous story of a bunch of guys in Brazil,
uh,
broke into a hospital to steal shit and they stole like a safe for scrap metal.
And the safe was a where they kept the cesium,
which is,
you know,
the,
it's,
it's radioactive material that they use for treating tumors and stuff.
And they had a high speed chase through the town and uh,
they had sort of cracked open the safe.
There was all the cesium was sorta this white powder was sort of falling out
around the town as the,
the cops were chasing them and they had to take the whole town brick by brick
and bury it under fucking concrete and led because it radiated the whole fucking
thing.
And this is just
from a hospital.
They had to take the whole town apart and bury it under,
under,
like led and,
and concrete.
So look,
my,
my whole thing is
terrified.
I'm terrified of that shit,
but I'm like,
and I don't believe we know what we're doing with the technology.
I'm terrified.
I'm terrified to proliferation.
However,
if you can take all those spent fucking fuel rods and power the world,
then at least shouldn't we give that a fucking shot?
Yes.
If we can really do that.
Uh,
I'm just joking around obviously about the gas,
Maddie's fuel and people up in math,
but if they can,
you know,
I mean,
I guarantee you it's going to be just like trying to get medical marijuana
illegal.
The pharmaceutical companies are going to lobby against it because they know
that you're going to lose money.
So the gas company's going to lobby against us because they know it's going to
cost them money.
Correct.
And dealt,
still play dirty because you're dealing with billions of while President Rogan
is there.
He's resonant.
Rolling.
Please.
People will have to be immortal around,
I'm going to have to do it remotely from Mars.
That's,
that's when President Roh Rogan runs everything from the Internet,
from Mars.
It's fucking earth would be a wasteland by then.
Everyone will be gone.
Mars would be like the gated community of space.
Yeah,
I'll fucking terraform with fake fake plants growing everywhere.
Everyone eating fake Chinese eggs and that'll be the day when people say the
hills and they're talking about Mars.
That's it.
Is it the hills though?
Subject to anymore.
Who's talking about the hills?
So I was talking to me about the hills.
I fucking plug my ears and I walk away.
Well,
I've been in La for three weeks now and people are,
there's a party in the hills.
We're going to the,
Oh,
I see.
I thought you meant the show.
No show called the hills,
right?
Wasn't that the one with the fucking the girl got all the plastic surgery.
Yeah.
Thank you.
You meet the Hollywood hills.
Yeah,
dude,
the Hollywood hills a terrible,
but what they're amazing for is that fucking view at night.
It's not like anywhere else in the world.
If you get high above doe Heeney I had a buddy used to have a house on
[inaudible].
It's incredible.
That view is like blade runner because you see the grid,
the the light grid at night.
It looks like shit during the day.
It looks like dog shit cause you just see gray buildings and and fucking smog.
But at nighttime it looks like a science fiction movie.
It's incredibly beautiful,
like way more beautiful than the neon lights of Vegas cause it's,
it's oddly symmetrical.
It's really fascinating because they're right above it.
It's like the perfect height above it for this amazing light show I got.
I got to see that.
Yeah,
it's dope.
It's a great place to live.
But as far as like,
you know,
places that you would want to actually live.
Other than that for that view,
it's fucking Hollywood hills.
Fairly douchey.
It's not just douchey.
It's dangerous.
I know two people that had been home invaded up there fuck off.
Oh yeah man.
There's a whole scam with people watching your house.
You don't,
you know,
people park cars and cases.
Sure.
Well there was a guy that was selling a house up there.
It's a fascinating story and a,
for a very brief time I thought about living up there.
I was like,
man,
it'd be nice.
I was closer to the comedy store.
I could just get down to the comedy store in 10 minutes.
I mean,
that would be kind of Nice.
Um,
so I,
it's just a fucking,
just not a committed thought at all.
Just a,
that's the view.
That's how spectacular that looks.
Look at that shit up there.
That's really what it looks like from my boy's house.
It was in cuffs were ratable.
His was even better than that.
His was a little lower.
He's like on the edge of what we're looking,
you're looking down at some houses and then that he was at the edge.
So all he saw was the grid and it was just magnificent.
So anyway,
this guy had this pretty nice house up there and he had a really pretty view
like that.
And,
uh,
I was thinking about it,
but I was like,
man,
I just don't like,
this house is so showy.
And it's like right on the street.
Like anyone could just wa,
I mean it's literally you could throw a person from the sidewalk and slam
through the window where you could pick someone up and use them as a rock to
hurl through this guy's window.
I was like,
that just doesn't make any sense to me.
And he'd go,
well,
it's got to be a state of the art security system.
I go,
what?
These cameras and you know what that is?
I go,
you're going to get a video of a dude with a ski mask robbing you.
This is what I said to him.
Two weeks later he was dead.
He shot in the neck,
in a home invasion in that very house.
Yeah.
He used to like hookers.
This guy who's crate and we used to call him wild man.
I had a buddy who worked at a strip club and uh,
this dude used to come in and he apparently invented like bell bottoms or
something nutty like that.
Like he invented something and made a fuck load of money.
And it was owl calls if you live in a glass house.
Yeah.
And he was getting a emphysema because of his,
um,
what are you doing dude?
That's just showing stuff like you're talking about.
Oh,
okay.
That does the same thing.
Um,
he was um,
he was getting emphysema from cigarettes and so he decided to quit the
cigarettes and his doctor told them,
look,
if you have to smoke smoke marijuana,
at least it's not going to kill you.
So this dude's are smoking marijuana and decides he doesn't want to work
anymore,
decides all he wants to do from now on.
He wants to play his guitar and then he wants to get prostitutes.
So he's got a lot of money and he thinks he's almost dead right?
Cause he had emphysema.
So he goes to the strip clubs and starts paying girls to have sex with them,
like incredible money,
like $3,000,
$4,000,
$5,000.
What am I going to pay you?
It's crazy.
Gravelly cigarette voice.
And apparently he was really rude to these girls and one of them came over to
his house and brought a guy and they,
the guy came in and robbed him and shot him in the neck.
And this was the very house that I was telling him,
you're going to get robbed by a dude with a ski mask and they got to get a nice
video of that and no one's ever going to catch that.
Right.
The heaviest a podcast ever.
Well it was,
he was a weird guy man.
This this guy wild man.
Cause it was when you hear like the mean shit that he would say to the girls or
even about the girls,
what,
it didn't make you sympathetic to him but you know on another hand like I
shouldn't get shot in the neck and his house.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the circumstances were.
I don't know if you had a comment,
I don't know what the fuck happened but I do know that the Hollywood hills gets
broken into a lot.
I had another friend who lived up there who caught a guy trying to break into
his house in the middle of the night.
There's,
um,
there's a lot of that,
a lot of that up there.
It's a tricky spot.
It's a tricky spot because it's,
uh,
it's so affluent and so accessible.
You know,
you're,
you drive three minutes,
you're on sunset,
you go left,
you go right,
you go down,
you go up,
you're gone.
You know,
so someone could like sneak in from a bad neighborhood slip up there.
It's not like Beverly hills where they have like constant drives where the cops
are called constantly cruising the neighborhood,
making sure there's no suspicious people and all that.
The Hollywood hills,
everybody's driving up there and wandering around so it gets,
uh,
it gets sketch.
Ice Tea got held up up there.
Ice Tea used to have a house in the Hollywood hills.
He got home invaded.
He got held up at gun.
It's pretty common.
I didn't know it was like that.
Yeah.
Well it's a lot of money whenever you have a lot of money.
I mean,
you see some of those houses up there,
they're fucking beautiful,
beautiful houses.
And you know,
you look at a house like that,
okay,
that house is worth $7 million.
So this motherfucker in his house got $7 million.
Well he's get some other shit in there too.
So you wait until someone's closing their garage and then you run out of the
bushes and boom,
you're in the garage and you can't get up there.
FASC it.
Cops can't get up there found.
You can't see it.
You're covered.
How are you going to call the cops too?
You don't get cell phone signal.
Your fucking house.
Eddie is a staying at the motel eights.
[inaudible] it's all done.
I'm just hanging out with the people that robbed them.
We'll add that.
You know,
as the economy gets,
there's a further and further gap between people with money because without
money it becomes more,
it becomes more and more dangerous
to flaunt it like that,
especially in the middle of a city.
True.
Like,
that's why I always freaked out about Hancock Park.
You know,
Hancock Park has these insanely beautiful homes,
the insanely beautiful like old world,
old Hollywood houses,
these giant mansions.
Like a friend of mine went over this guy's house and she said that he has like a
theater in his house,
like a full theater with velvet curtains and incredible gold guild work.
And the house was built in the 20s like some fucking Cary grant guy built it and
he said,
it's amazing and it's fucking five blocks from east La,
right?
Five blocks from a store where all the signs are in Spanish,
you know,
and you're,
you're living in this crazy stupid mansion that's so close to like abject
poverty.
Well I was starting on people.
That's exactly what you get is dangerous.
But speaking about Florida,
yeah,
I always think that,
I think that when I go to Miami,
right,
because you go on one side of the,
and it's like baby blue Bentleys and,
and like these crazy like Pan House,
like $20 million places.
And literally on the other side,
it's like El Salvadorian,
Guatemala and sorta like,
you know,
99 cent but booze,
those kind of thing.
And you're like,
why don't these dudes from this side of the street who by the way of growing up
in El Salvador and they're not sorta any stranger to hard times,
walk across and just take it,
you guys fucking car.
Why wouldn't you do that?
Well,
because they're honorable people and they're happy.
They're not in El Salvador.
They don't want to get arrested in Americans.
So they get kicked out.
I would do it if I was broke and starving,
I would go across and click here to make their own dreams come true.
Not to steal the dreams of another man.
If I was poor and starving,
I w and some guy's driving a car worth 250 grand,
I would take it right there.
Are they pouring starving or are they just poor?
I would be.
I want to.
I wouldn't be starving.
Yeah,
you have to be starving a lot.
Most people are just poor,
poor and starving number's pretty small.
I think I wouldn't take it,
but I would definitely take a shit on your hood.
I just want to fuck your shit up,
but I don't want to steal.
Why be a hater like that?
Why shouldn't I Mansa the guy works so hard to get a nice car and he decided to
keep it in the neighborhood.
And what do you do your shit on a set like a big Ar brings me no enjoyment,
but my shit on that hood is brings.
Oh well that's cause you got to hate her mentality.
He shouldn't give you enjoyment because she should give you hope.
You should look at that and say,
look,
this asshole can make that money.
What's,
why is he better than me?
He's not.
So this is inspiration.
You use it for fuel.
Go on and get your own car.
Shit on his car.
All you're going to think about is,
man,
I hope I don't have a car like this says some asshole like me.
He's going to come along and shit on it.
It would be like,
I can't wait til the day.
There's some asshole like me that shits on my car when I had that.
Cause when you have that car you're like,
I'm glad you mad.
I'm so glad.
You're glad enough that someone steps on your hood,
dense your fucking hood and it shits on it.
That is just rude,
disrespectful property and you can't sell that anytime.
I can call that in America when I buy a car nut,
I'm just going to that someone one day will shit on this hood.
They like they,
I listen to Joe Rogan,
I'm going to go find his car shit on his own.
That is so rude.
I can't believe you put that out there because it's going to come back and it's
going to land right in your fucking dashboard.
So I'm just going to take video now about shit.
They got to punch a hole straight through your dashboard.
Just threads to your windshield so they can shit directly under your dashboard.
How dare you?
How dare you even think like that upper deck or sunroof shit.
Even the more pro move.
Well,
it really,
if you want to shit in your own hand,
then smear it in that upper part where you can never clean it out.
That's what I'm saying.
If you want to really fuck up a guy's car,
but why would you do then man,
that's bad energy.
You do.
You're doing well.
You don't need to do this.
You're a successful man.
Can't be hating on some dude with a badly,
it's just ridiculous.
It's a shitty car.
It's going to break down in them anyway.
It's going to leave on the side of the highway.
I've got a friend who has a Rolls Royce.
It breaks,
breaks,
breaks all the time.
Things go wrong.
Ac gets stuck on this fucking thing goes wrong.
Radio doesn't work.
This speakers out there,
it's a fucking Rolls Royce and it doesn't make sense.
Great.
You can buy like,
you know on Lincoln,
you can buy these sort of old like,
you know,
Shit Brown seventies rollers for like five grand and every time I go to Vegas
I'm like,
I ain't got to come back with a brick or two and just buy a shit brown roller
and get like a punk kid with a safety pin through his neck or know ms 13 kid to
just drive me around town,
sorta roll,
roll up to the bars and my Shit Brown 77 Rolls Royce and be like,
I am I late for the party and you know,
and just have this kid,
you know,
facial tattoos be my driver.
That's not a bad move is make people uncomfortable shit on that hood.
If that kid was driving,
you would let that slide,
but you wouldn't shit on the hood of a 77 year old car,
1977 car anyway,
no,
that car,
I would respect that whip.
I know a dude,
uh,
cliffy beef from epic games.
He was telling us that he had a Lamborghini Aventador.
It's like 400 plus thousand dollars and then it broke and door handle broke.
Had a climbing from his girlfriend's side or she had a climb over and open up
his door.
Just stop.
Ya Know,
if I spent that much money on a car and he had to like make my Dick Vigor and
fix all my problems in life,
well it's a,
it's a goddamn space ship that,
that Lamborghini,
but it's,
it's just so ridiculous.
He can't make it not break thought.
Fuck man.
Jesus Christ.
You're getting angry over there.
I'm a little mad.
They can't get it together.
Expensive cars should not break.
They do though.
Those are the ones that break,
you know,
it doesn't break Honda accords.
Those motherfuckers are bulletproof because if they break them,
they do a recall a Subaru and drive through the snow.
You'll never get stuck.
You know?
Look at that.
There's a Lamborghini Aventador.
I mean that might as well be a God damn spaceship.
Is that a Mercia Lago events door broken down in London?
Oh,
it's broken down.
Ha.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
they break,
man.
There were not really designed to be used.
They just cool.
They're just a massive feat of engineering and twisted steel.
Oh quarter together with fucking screws and they just stomp on that explosion
box they call an engine and hope it all stays together as it rattles apart.
Plus it's built by guineas.
Don't trust my people,
my people not to be trusted with,
with very like fine technical things.
It mean Ferrari.
The only reason why they keep it together as their rich heritage and racing and
their ego and winning racing.
Because if you take all that out of the loop,
there are a bunch of guineas to a bunch of guineas building cars.
You really trust him.
They're going to stare at some chicks ass walking by.
I forget a screw and you're fucking wheels going to go flying off when you're on
turn three.
I mean,
you guys are the only people that originally borrowed technology from Chinese
people.
This is one word.
Guy Gets hit by a car.
If you back that up,
you could see it.
You didn't see it in this video.
If you look at this,
boom.
Okay.
I turns right into him like a spastic.
The dude has a right away to and boom and that's a $488,000 car.
Yeah,
it's snapped in half.
Apparently the cars are designed to break away like that and the event of a
serious collision.
That's an Aventador.
Oh,
that's the carbon fiber.
While the Lamborghini Aventador.
Wow.
There anything made by guineas.
They take long breaks in the middle of the day.
They take naps,
they drink wine at work.
Those people are fucking savages.
All they're thinking about is putting that car together and making enough money
so that they can just fuck for six months.
Great track suits though.
Yeah.
They make good track suits.
They were wearing
tracksuits still fly in New York.
La has not embraced the tracksuit.
Never did.
If you like show up and you're hanging around a track suit,
they assume you're either Armenian or you're from New York.
Armenians can Baraka track suit in La Nla they're great,
man.
I don't fuck with buttons or zippers anymore.
Smart.
I should have been on that a long time ago because I'm not scared of a fanny
pack.
Fanny pack with a track suit is an excellent combination.
I'd rather just be fat and wear elastic bands and look awesome and perfect,
but even if you're skinny,
it's still comfortable.
I'm just going to wear pajamas.
I'm just wearing like weather resistant pajamas.
That's the best.
Rodney Dangerfield back and is back in the dizzy.
I'm used to go on stage.
Rondi would wear a bathrobe,
nothing on underneath and with slippers and just walk on stage.
And it was because,
you know,
it prevented,
I think it prevented,
uh,
you know anybody from taking him seriously because he's not out there with a
suit on.
I mean,
right away you're like,
you're laughing and you're like,
look,
we have Rodney.
He opened shirt.
So you know,
it was obvious it was nothing on underneath there wearing slippers.
But it was also,
he was so loose because he came out there with a bathrobe on that he was just
giving no fucks out there.
Powerful Rodney Dangerfield for Rodney Dangerfield and he,
that was an original move.
I'd never heard anybody doing that before him and he did it later in his career,
so it was most likely born out of one day.
He was backstage in his bathrobe and they said,
Rodney,
you're on.
And he's like,
okay,
I'm on fucking put it lay.
There he is.
That's how he used to walk and his package was always hanging out.
Wow.
Apparently at a monster hog too.
He didn't give a fuck.
Meet Peeping Rodney Dangerfield and there wasn't a,
what was it,
bread skeleton or something.
Who was the guy who ran the famous
Milton Berle?
Oh,
Milton Berle famous for his giant hog and his love of stolen jokes.
Famous joke thief with a giant hug.
That was the word back in the day,
but I think joke thief was a different sort of thing back then.
I think they all had like gags and they use them into the interchange them like
guy would work the Catskills,
then another guy would work.
They would do like a lot of the same material.
There was nobody writing anything down back then.
There was no blogs or people get shit on you for doing that.
There was also,
if you steal someone's joke now,
is it a big deal?
Yeah.
If you get caught stealing someone's joke now you're fucked.
Really?
Yeah.
This is about who?
By the Internet.
The Internet.
We'll find out and they'll expose it and I think people won't take you
seriously.
What about your man,
Shiela booth?
Yeah,
we talking about that on the podcast or was it before the Friday?
Before the podcast?
Yeah.
Apparently he um,
made a short film and it's an almost an entire verbatim rip off,
including the imagery of some old comic book.
Really.
Joe was telling me about it.
It sounded just like,
damn you got caught.
Yeah.
You got caught.
And what did he say?
I Dunno.
I mean he,
he's pulling it down and um,
I dunno if he's actually made a public,
I'm sure if I just Google Shaya I forgive him.
I loved him and transformers.
Ah,
uh,
okay.
Let's plagiarism pool age or,
Yup.
That's it.
That is my favorite thing to do in la though.
People try to like stunt on you at parties about their new projects,
like,
oh,
I have a project with so and so and I'll just pick their worst movie and be
like,
I loved him and transformers,
or I loved him in Van Wilder.
Like that's my favorite thing to do.
Someone was telling me about what they do.
They'll just be like,
oh,
I got this guy and I'm doing this new movie with him.
You're going to see them in a whole New Light.
And I was like,
you know what?
I'd love to see Ryan metals in Van Wilder too.
Wow,
okay.
In a series of tweets,
he admitted on Tuesday that he fucked up in quotes by failing to acknowledge the
short film he passed off as an original work was actually inspired by,
if not an entire rip off of a graphic novella written by artists.
Daniel close by way of apology laboo is that what you're saying?
The booth,
that's what he deserves.
The tweeted in that his excitement and naivete as an amateur film maker,
he got lost in the creative process and neglected to follow proper
accreditation.
Wow.
That's not,
that's nonsense.
I want Alec Baldwin to release a statement about this naivete and excitement may
well have played their part in this fairly brazen breach of etiquette.
But considering the booze,
previous run ins with plagiarism,
oh my God,
he did something else.
What is it?
What did this guy before?
What was he accused of before?
But stealing dining clouds,
you're going to get caught.
I mean,
he's a famous,
yeah,
well he's this guy.
He's not that smart
answers to think they're way smarter than they are.
They get really confused because everybody listens to him on the set.
And that's how they judge.
Like they're,
they're like their ecosystem.
Like,
oh well obviously I'm a fucking big deal.
You know,
like I know you're a big deal on a set and the people are delusional and they,
well,
you're delusional because people are,
they're not being honest with you all.
And then you go to a red carpet thing and they're not,
you know,
you're doing transformers.
Everyone's throwing fucking softballs at.
Yeah.
So you're,
you're super confused as to where you are in the world.
So you think,
wow,
just rip off this fucking old school.
He comic book.
I mean,
him and Bumblebee are still legends to me too.
So Real,
real recent comic book to 2007 comic dump,
Fuck Dumb Fuck.
Copying isn't particularly creative,
creative work,
being inspired by someone else's idea to produce something new and different is
creative work.
What does that mean?
That's one of the dumbest things I've ever,
that's like the weirdest,
weirdest admission slash ego chest puff copying is in particularly creative
work,
being inspired by someone else's work to produce something new and different is
creative work.
But,
but he copied and he also said,
I didn't mean to copy,
I forgot to acknowledge it,
but uh,
I was creative anyway.
And they're also saying that his apology might've been plagiarized.
No Way.
Yes.
His apology apparently looks familiar to someone else's apology for,
for,
um,
for doing that.
Oh my goodness.
Oh,
he took the Picasso quote is what they trying to say?
No.
Did,
did he say that?
I guess he paraphrased.
No,
that's not,
that's,
that's nitpicking.
Yeah.
Unless they have a better exam,
plagiarized and apology.
I actually would've like giving him props and like that's amazing.
Got The talent that you thought to plagiarizing policy like you so cold and
don't give a fuck that I now love you.
Yeah.
Maybe puts blinders on.
Just fucking plows right through it all.
We put this merely copying is in particularly creative work,
although it's useful and training practice,
being inspired by someone else's idea to produce something new and different is
creative work and it may have even washed analyze the stolen concept.
Oh my God did steal it.
Wow.
From now or years ago.
Look at that answered four years ago.
You scumbag.
Oh,
he's one of those guys.
He's one of those guys.
He doesn't have his own thoughts.
Next time I get in an argument,
I'm going to just plagiarize Shiela booths.
Apologies.
Start sending them via email to people.
Well,
that makes sense because that's w that's sort of how I perceive a lot of actors.
I always perceive a lot of actors being completely delusional and also being
completely fraudulent,
like not giving you who they really are,
but giving you what they think would be nice if you thought of them and that's
clearly what he did by not just plagiarizing,
but by plagiarizing the fucking apology.
Yes.
Obviously he this dump fuck even capitalize the his as well.
He's such a dump.
Cut.
He did.
He caught plagiarizing Charles boot Koski oh shit.
Oh my God.
Cause this is this the old problem that he had six hours ago.
Oh Jesus Christ.
How did he plagiarized boot Koski I don't even want to know you.
Fuck this dummy.
He stole the plot
from a poet,
Charles mccalsky and author Ben Wa.
I'm not going to say it.
Oh,
who cares.
I'm going to bootleg bootlegger Yan can cook episode and turn it in Shane and
then send you shy the boobs.
A policy via email and capitalize is,
that's what comedian,
I'm sorry,
I forgot to credit Martin Yan for this episode.
He plagiarize his fucking apology from Yahoo answers you dumb,
dumb,
dumb dumb.
But you were right earlier you said,
look,
you do anything on the Internet and yeah,
you can't get away with that kind of stupid shit.
Right.
All Day.
He's been re tweeting people's respond or apologies like major apologies over
the last couple of years.
Like Tigers,
major apology.
Yeah.
In 2009,
um,
Kanye is response to Taylor swift when he took over her.
And what does he do?
Oh,
retreating them.
He's just doing that to try to try to cover up the fact they got caught
plagiarizing.
Not just somebody who's work but an apology.
She's now a victim just,
well,
I don't think he's doing that.
I think he's just throwing a bunch of fucking decoys up in the air.
I mean,
he's just tweeting a bunch of shit.
Oh yeah,
that,
well,
I also tweeted Kanye West's apology.
I also tweeted that is the best way to get people distracted though,
is if you're in some shit right now.
Like,
Hey,
have you seen this Kanye West interview?
Yeah.
But that's kind of the easiest way to get people distracted.
That's a good way.
Yeah.
Which is the Connie,
which one?
Any of them.
Him caught himself.
Michelangelo.
Okay.
You don't got dance a saying,
you don't got the answers.
I'm Michelangelo in the flesh.
You,
we need the family to step up and recognize I'm in the flesh.
Nike is a slave master.
I was like,
what the fuck dude?
Rap Stars are the Rock Stars and I'm the biggest one.
Aww.
That's so silly.
You don't get to be the biggest one if you say that because that's not something
you would ever imagine Mick Jagger Sang.
Right?
Right.
Do you think that Bono from u two would ever say that?
Who you know,
rock stars don't say that.
They just live it.
You live it.
You don't say,
let everybody else say it.
When you start saying it yourself,
you're not that.
That's not you.
You're not that bad because of real bad motherfuckers.
Bad motherfucker across the board and bad motherfuckers don't brag like that.
Especially saying stupid shit like I'm Michelangelo.
I'm Disney.
No,
you're not.
Because they wouldn't say that.
They're not.
They're not comparing themselves to the previous people and
some loudy shouty sort of way.
That's silly.
You would like a v neck on.
Yeah.
You're fucking silence white tee shirts on.
It's the idea behind it is preposterous that a guy's going to yell out that he's
not getting his just due and he's the Disney and he's the Steve Jobs.
He's like,
come on man.
No you're not.
That's exactly proof that you're not and because you saying you are and the guys
who are don't say they're somebody else like that.
It just do.
The funniest reason too is that his reason for being so mad and talking about
being a new slave,
it's because he can't break into fashion now.
It makes no fucking sense.
Doesn't have to make sense.
It's all fueled by ego.
It's just this
ego that he has to dam up doesn't even want to do like high end female.
Yeah,
not much.
And you're like,
oh you want to,
you wanna you wanna design dresses.
But it's so who gives a fuck?
Because it's like,
why are you yelling about that on a rap radio station?
If you're going to dress like Kim Kardashian,
it doesn't take much.
Just take some Reynold's wrap clear Reynolds wrap and wrap it around that bitch
like that is the best thing she will look like.
Do you really believe that?
Do you really don't?
You don't think that there's like probably addressed it with better than
surrender?
No,
I think her and Saran wrap would be amazing.
I think there's a problem with Saran wrap and a big problem is that the shit is
hard to get off.
Oh you got to like fucking rip it and pull it
and go and dress,
hike that sucker up and if you fuck a girl is covering Saran wrap,
their pitch is going to be sweaty.
It's going to be like rivers is sweat coming out of the lower back and say,
man,
I was at this pimps and hoes party in high school and I put this girl up there
was doing a keg stand and she just wore Reynold's wrap when no underwear and I
was like,
this is the best dress
ever.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
Halloween or this is what,
this is just what pimps and hoes party [inaudible] party.
This is what people do in coldest sags in Orlando.
Orlando.
Sorry.
What was the purpose of,
what was the purpose of the
of the Reynolds ripe to be sexy.
Yes.
That was her whole outfit.
Wow.
Well that works.
I mean that's obvious.
You're not classy.
You know,
you're wrapping yourself up in Wales.
You definitely hold on as her underwear or that was her dress,
her dress and there was no underwear.
No,
there was no,
she went up there for the kid.
Thought I thought you said it looked like she was selling Turkey,
but I thought you said she was,
she was going up for a,
a cake stand,
like wearing a dress.
The dress fell down and all she was running as underwear.
It was rental drop and I was like,
oh,
she's a,
she's a freak.
You know,
She was just wearing Reynold's wrap.
I don't think Turkey
Burger Line got enough respect.
I know.
Give it a little bit of a pause it Saran wrap on both sides looking and you see
in the meat.
I like it.
I like where you went with that.
Pimps and hoes party man.
Those fucking movies.
Pimps up hoes down the best.
Oh my God.
Those are real documentaries.
Yeah.
Mr. White for white folks,
white folks,
white pimp in this old fucking redone like 1930s car.
This duty is to drive around his white suits and they would get together and Mr.
White,
they would all like rap,
pimp style.
They will all like rap at each other.
I'm telling you,
Mount Rushmore of light people,
Kenny powers,
Al Bundy,
Mr. White folks.
That is the white person.
Mount Rushmore.
You know Mr [inaudible],
Mr [inaudible],
Mr [inaudible] folks,
man,
people have slept on Mr. White folks.
You got to listen to him talk.
No.
Oh,
I really got my feet wet in the game,
right.
I was Eddy Moretti before I got my feet.
Just started calling me white folks and ever since then it just stuck.
Look,
he's had a pimp and a,
I guess date function.
Are these like classy people say these are the excellent,
a global creative director of [inaudible].
I love his voice.
Africa like a can,
American southern slang thing.
You know
how to dress.
Look at this money and dollar bills,
how to finesse.
But you know,
I got educated in the hood.
I feel like a,
that was a blessing for me being Caucasian and you know,
to be able to come to the other side of the fence,
you know,
when uh,
be accepted and uh,
also,
uh,
you know,
being able to do some of the things that,
uh,
some of the likes of the past that have done sort of like a ball capitol
football shirt and then just talk like,
or like,
you know,
in a suit,
IBM sales dude or whatever you just talked about.
One thing about white girls,
you know,
this is my favorite.
They get less problems with the police.
You know,
they don't get that much daddy.
Well,
black vest,
we wanted to get in the street next stupid,
you know,
be wanting to fight with the tricks and fight with the police and talking crazy
and
she can't take care of no business like that.
Yeah.
Like you know,
people love coffee and cigarettes that shot at like deal Murray.
We had risen all of them,
but the best shot in a coffee shop ever is those fuckers drinking soup at the
end of this girl.
That's the illest shot.
I think that the females respect the game like they once did because there are
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of renegades and out.
Wow.
That's a female working and doesn't have a man.
Rarely comes into [inaudible].
Sure.
First of all,
hilarious
is not supposed to be looking at a pimp when a pimp ride by this supposed to be
looking at the motherfucking curve
and when she looked up at a pimp,
she can't be broke for reckless eyeballing.
Look at this guy chasing him around.
She can be broke for reckless eyeballing reckless.
That means that she's making eye contact with the Pippin and she may not even be
with that man.
You know,
that's the reason why I say the game has changed.
In the old days she'd be on the pimp arrests.
What a weird thing to be proud of.
So you know what a weird thing to be proud of to be a guy who makes women sell
their bodies,
but you know,
talk about the things that the great pimps,
the past.
I've been blessed to be able to do some of that shit.
The great pimps that a pass.
What happens?
Darker on the pimps.
The famous one pimps up hoes down and hookers at the point.
No,
no.
This is your other one?
The one that was in the movie theater.
Yeah.
What was the one that we were here?
It was John Singleton did.
It was like Fillmore slum.
Yeah.
Who the fuck was that one?
I don't remember,
but it was,
God damn it wasn't,
I don't remember it.
There's a famous pimp movie shit.
Yeah,
that was a good one too.
That might have been even better than pimps.
They were called Pimp American Mexican American Mexican American parents.
Yeah.
They're both really good man.
It's a weird world band.
And they have those pimp conventions and Oh,
remember remembering pimps up hoes down ice tea went to the pimp convention and
started telling everybody that he was a pimp and he was like rapping and talking
about how he's not really a rapper.
He's just a pimp.
Yes.
Okay.
I thought you were on that special victims unit show.
No,
no,
no.
Never seen it.
Just pimping.
You got confused.
Dog Ice tea.
Straight pimping.
He's getting his hair done in the show.
Talking about the pimp game.
Had the pimp cane with the pimp came,
taught him about rap.
Okay.
That's something that white guy can't pull off.
Cv Four.
Imagine if a white guy did that and then got on one of those special victims
unit shows
and then,
well,
you know the special victim unit shows too.
They're all about rape,
you know,
so it feels like if he's on that and he says,
he says he used to sell pussy and he used to sell plus he's not a rape show.
Yeah.
That's kind of a conflict of interest.
That's just like the bankers,
the financial lists to the SEC hiring.
Yeah,
it's exactly professors.
It's basically the same thing.
That doesn't,
that doesn't make sense at all.
Nice to you.
Silly man ain't hurting nobody on,
on Special Investigations Unit though as Vu.
Is that what is cost for you?
Is that what it is?
I don't know.
He's not hurting anybody,
so no,
he's not.
In fact keep them off the streets.
Right.
A lot of girls.
There he is.
Look at this.
He's not talking montage.
Oh,
there's gotta be one that hasn't talking five.
The one cause he's got his hair's in.
It's pretty funny.
It's weird though.
It's,
but that's,
that's a weird aspect of the black community.
It doesn't exist in the white community.
Like there,
there wouldn't be like a,
a bunch of white dudes sitting around talking about the pimp game.
There's not enough of them.
You got Mr. White folks.
Dude,
it's one,
one guy.
I think you probably have two things running,
right?
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
It's just,
it's weird that that was not that long ago,
but I think you'd,
you'd feel a lot more criticism if you're going to put a movie out,
sort of a glorifying the life of essentially a criminal who owned slaves.
Women.
Sure.
That wouldn't,
that wouldn't fly today,
I don't think.
I think people would really complain because all the pimps up hoes down came out
a long time
game.
It was like,
Yo,
you that action is doing this.
No,
my idols,
iceberg slim,
I'm naming
and have her do an eight.
Then I could sit in front of this white man and break him down exact same way.
It ain't no difference.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause I don't want no puts.
I never want to put he on my bed,
you know what I'm saying?
So I'm like,
okay,
I'm up in the play this motherfucker.
I'm really fitting to see how far I can take this shit.
And um,
I've been doing it ever since I came to ask.
I really came act,
I ain't no rapper.
I got,
it's all,
it's all game.
Ain't nobody.
I'm this,
I'm this work.
And these Niggas when that,
and then the funny thing is when I get out of here,
when I deal with different individually,
but you know you ain't there.
I'm like,
maybe it's not a problem.
That's not a problem.
I got a problem.
If I could,
I could still do it better now than ever.
I could.
Not 95% of any Niggas bitches.
I know I can do this shit.
It's not a problem,
man,
but it's like that was a new adventure for me when he get over here and real
niggas can see it.
They said,
this Nigga
my mind,
I'm not high enough to watch that real knowledge.
You're not ready for it?
I think so.
I need more Alpha brain.
I'm not quite ready for that level.
I had too much off from brain.
I'm into my cerebral cortex right now.
Yeah.
I don't even know how we got on this whole pimps up
to the vortex.
Not as depressing as the hookers and the point series.
That's the most depressing shit or kill a season I showed you last time.
Yes.
There's a lot of those depressing prostitute videos.
That's some depressing shit.
Was hookers on the point?
The where all the cars drive by us?
It just falls to him.
Everything.
The Bronx.
Bronx.
Yeah.
This is apparently one area that's just got point.
Yeah,
it's just got the worst case.
They have a great farmer's market that's point.
Fantastic.
Farmer's market.
The produce is amazing out there.
And so did the hookers just come out at night and the farmer's markets done and
then just the atmosphere changes radically.
They sell fish,
then they sell fruit fish.
Then they sell fish.
Are they still doing that?
It's a fun Hunt's point.
Did they clean it up after that show?
Uh,
I'm not sure.
I just go for the farmer's market.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I understand.
But I mean,
when you're at the farmer's market,
do you see like a daytime vampire?
Stragglers are still a,
I've never seen him putting sunscreen on venturing out of the cave.
We've been here with one of the best chefs in the world.
We haven't talked about food once.
Oh No.
We talked about fake food.
We did.
That is true.
You're such an all around.
Cool Dude.
Nobody would imagine that you are one of the best chefs in the world.
You like,
you think of a great chef,
you think of someone that's like impossible to reach,
some strange,
very introspective artists,
creative type.
And I consider myself just a very dope sandwich.
Artists like greatest subway worker of all time.
What is this driving you crazy?
All this gluten free shit.
Again,
angry people.
I mean I'm allergic to a lot of stuff.
I actually did this test because I was having trouble on the road and I was
having stomach issues and I got food poisoning a few times.
So I did these tests.
I'm allergic to dairy,
beef,
lamb,
all kinds of things.
You're allergic to lamb.
So,
well what I,
I take supplements and then I can have things like,
it's going to affect me regardless.
Like,
or what do you mean make you make you fart?
I get diarrhea.
I fart.
I burped and like I kind of,
um,
I have other issues,
right?
Like man boobs,
Sam,
the come from eating the wrong foods.
The allergies can affect you in so many different ways.
But I'm like highly sensitive to like beef,
lamb,
dairy,
eggs,
all these weird foods.
So I've been seeing like this nutritionist,
I still eat it because I love to cook.
I love to eat it,
but it's just about managing it,
you know?
So what do they know what's happening at rarely?
I can only have it like,
like beef or lamb.
I'll eat once a month now.
Do they know what the cause of all this stuff is?
Is this something,
I'm imagining beef and lamb forever.
Forever.
Did you feel ill affects of it and that's why you went and get it checked out?
Did it progressively get worse?
I've always had like intestinal issues and things like that.
It's not something that progressively got worse.
It was something that was always a case.
It's something that's always the case.
And then,
um,
they,
they can't tell me because they didn't test me before for it.
Like food allergies is kind of a new thing.
Like not everybody's gotten tested for food allergies.
That's something people got to check out.
But do you think it got worse after you were became a chef?
I mean,
I definitely more weird shit,
man.
I definitely felt worse than my stomach.
I mean,
I was farting all over the place.
Like my friends.
Like you sound like a fucking machine gun.
It's just a walking farm.
That's crazy that you're allergic to beef and lamb.
Weird things.
My eyes get irritated.
It's kind of crazy.
There's a such weird things to be a,
how is it to go around the world doing a cooking show if you can't eat like the
two most?
Well,
he's still,
he,
I just eat it and I take those supplements.
And what are the settlements that help you?
Do you take the adjustive enzymes?
I take a og wash route.
There's something like hogwash route.
There's grape seed extract and methyl assists probiotics.
Um,
and then the thing is when I'm not doing the shows and I'm not researching
foods,
I keep it really clean.
Right.
So what does your diet consist of then when you're saying you can eat greens?
I eat seafood.
I can eat pork and chicken.
So chickens too.
Hmm.
That's fascinating.
Lamb and beat.
What about venison,
elk,
things along those lines?
I'm not sure.
They didn't test me for that,
so I got to figure it out,
but no food allergies is real.
How did you become a chef?
If every time you eat
fucking,
you're starting up a storm.
Yeah,
I followed it up with so I think it was just how it was.
A kid used to sign my yearbook,
this one kid,
because I had so much like sinus issues.
He was like,
and I farted all the time and I always needed to poop.
life is a highway,
bring tissues.
He signed my yearbook that way in like sixth grade.
That's funny man.
What a weird circumstance to be found in.
Did they have any reason why they believe that you got allergic to all these
things?
Like when they find out food allergies,
do they have a source for these?
Is it genetic?
I think for me it's genetic.
You're family has the same issues.
My mom has a lot of the same issues.
No.
I had also the weirdest thing I had developed in Mongolia.
Right.
I got sick in Mongolia and I had to take antibiotics to like flush my system
out.
I got back to America and went to see this doctor and he's like,
dude,
you got a yeast infection.
I was like,
I thought I needed a vagina to have a yeast infection.
He's like,
no,
you have a yeast infection in your stomach and you cleaned it out.
Antibiotics and the bad bacteria got in before the good bacteria can be the yes.
Yet you had it too.
No,
no but,
but,
but no,
I didn't have a yeast infection.
I think the deal is,
is like everyone has candida because I have every symptom of it,
but it's like,
oh,
if you spit white and you fucking,
how about that fucking thing that you were telling me about the last time we
talked,
that crazy bug that you had?
Well,
your stomach,
I was just going to say I've had all this crazy shit cause you go basically if
you go like sub Saharan Africa,
you know,
Afghanistan,
lots of rural parts of India,
you're going to get some shit.
And so,
uh,
by the way,
I promised my wife I wouldn't talk about my bowel movements.
Uh,
again on your show.
She has a problem with that.
But I,
yeah,
I had this,
a helmet headed,
a flesh eating parasite and my bowels.
Uh,
and I had to get it out and all this shit.
Anyway,
I,
if you ever go,
you look,
if you're not,
you know,
you go.
Then afterwards,
after you get the shit done,
you're like,
okay,
I'll have a,
I'll bring cereal bars and drinking,
bring my home water.
And like eventually,
like,
you know,
you're going to eat some,
you're going to drink something,
you're going to get some.
But what I just find amazing,
cause I,
I'm kind of a regular guy and whenever,
but you go to these places,
you're just,
you're going to pick up a as it just happens.
But you know,
for a guy who has stomach problems to become a traveling,
the world chef that makes Anthony Bourdain looked like a fucking,
you know,
he's in short pants is a,
a very,
as is even
a more of a courageous choice.
Cause you're going to the weirdest countries in the world,
eating the weirdest food in the world when a cheeseburger will make you shit
your brains out.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I go crazy out there.
I bring a lot of,
I eat a lot of baroque and I eat a lot of probiotics and I had just have to keep
it real.
Rocha,
the British,
my multivitamin.
That's a hangover cure.
Yeah.
I take it just on the regular from it.
What is it?
How does it,
how does it,
what does it Morocco,
I call it.
It's like,
it's,
it's better than an emergency.
All that,
it just be 12 vitamins.
It's like a rush of it,
but it really gets you,
it's an effervescent tablet.
That's like a super hangover cure in England.
Oh,
I see.
So you dropped this in water and it's like a lot of B 12 I used that a lot,
but um,
no man,
it's tough to do the show on the road,
but I love it cause I've,
I didn't know I was allergic.
I thought that that's just how you feel after eating.
So 31 years.
I don't have a problem doing it,
but my doctor was like,
look,
if you want to live long,
you don't want to wake up everyday with diarrhea and like Kinda like nasal
issue.
Then you need to change the way you eat.
So now I just,
you'll see in season two I'm sneezing all the time,
everywhere.
How are your shifts?
No solid,
solid,
strong.
The thing either was that horse,
did you eat horse?
I I drank fermented horses.
Milk with the nastiest thing was that's the alcoholic beverage.
Fermented Marysville ferments and horses and milk might be another thing.
Fermented Mare's milk.
That's what the Mongols Seamus and it clears your system out too.
It's like it detoxes you.
If it's your first time drinking it really,
you don't clear you.
I want to go,
I want to do that.
How does it detox?
The tastes like shit or that's what they tell you it,
it doesn't taste all right.
It sounds like it's going to taste bad,
but it doesn't taste bad.
It is.
It does feel like on clarifying shocker,
it feels like you're inside a horses ass.
But in a sweet way
cause it's like I can't picture,
you can't get around it that it's the fermented essence of this animal and that
bothers you at first,
but then you're like,
it's kind of sweet.
It has a sweet and like delicate flavor.
It tastes like a horse.
It tastes like a fucking horse.
[inaudible] would sell if you brought it back to the horse with rapt and honey.
That's what it looks like in that bottle.
The white bottle that's up there.
That's what it looked like.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Like a fermented Mare's milk.
Mare's milk.
Like they had it in a wooden bucket and they'd just ladle it into bowls.
They just let it rot.
There was pieces of Hay in it.
All right,
because hey would just fly into it and I was fucking with these people.
I want to drink.
That was actually good in a clean v out.
But she makes you shit.
I just shit my,
listen,
I didn't know if that's good.
Lamb chop makes you shit.
Well yeah.
Different in a different kind of shapes.
Porosity.
This was explosive.
This,
this rock me like
from the mayor's milk.
Yeah.
This shit just ran out of me like my ass.
Was Stan on south farm?
Do you think that this would be something that could be successfully bottled and
then don't have a colon?
I'm sure people in Williamsburg and Bushwick wheel by fermenting Williams,
the hip section of Brooklyn,
right.
Should bought vice should start bottling.
Know somebody came to us and said we should make advice moonshine,
like a vice whiskey.
White whiskey.
That's a good idea.
You should do.
We should do a vice fucking marriage.
What's holding you back?
It's like if you like and got cash to make it roll,
suddenly come boots it.
They will be shitting their,
this is all eddies fucking fermented.
Mare's milk St.
Let's make White Brooklyn Shit there.
I'm a big fan of Kombucha.
Do you drink Kombucha at all?
Talking about probiotics.
That's shit's great for you.
It won't get you lit up.
That mirror feel real bad.
I just drink terrible.
He's drank booze.
Heroine.
I think you go to places that are so fucked up that you get back here.
You're like,
whatever.
No.
But I can I tell you one thing,
there's four blue zones
in the world.
You know what blue zone is like where people live well into their hundreds and,
and a lot of them,
um,
Costa Rica where I write,
where I have a house where they just drink a lot of booze and smoke a lot of
dope in Crete,
uh,
and Sardinia,
which is again,
just dude,
they just drinking wine all day.
Like they don't get wasted,
but you know,
they're drinking wine all day,
eating fish,
doing whatever while they eat everything.
And uh,
one IV in the caucuses near uh,
near,
um,
Dagestan were they walking up and down the mountains and they eat,
they eat the same thing.
Are they lamb and vegetables and shit.
And then the,
the last one is this part of Japan,
you know,
where they,
they the like burdock root every day and stuff.
But anyway,
uh,
they all drink booze,
they and,
and a lot of booze and the,
and the one thing is consistency of that.
They paid basically the same thing every day.
Well,
you have a liver.
I mean liver can process booze.
It's just a matter of how much booze you're drinking.
So that's what we're talking.
I seen some of those studies.
I figure it's the happiness factor and the like.
I agree.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think that stress is probably the killer way worse than almost anything else
you do.
Killer.
Especially like real stress like this.
People that can't go to bed at night,
they get home from work and they're fucking a wire to the gills.
Thinking about the office and all the things they have to get done and all the
competition and the social politics that are playing on.
And then they sleep for a couple hours and they get up and they're fucked up.
So they take a pill and then they fucking keep going.
And two grandmothers,
one lift
to 99 one lived to 101 and the,
neither of them ever had a job and the and the,
and at two o'clock in the afternoon it was cocktail hour til it was 99 at night.
That was it.
They just got was that they got
lit up every well half like wow.
For four hours every day,
which they all worked up to.
That was,
that was it.
We just going to,
now we're going to have a heart cocktails and then we're going to go to sleep
and that's it.
That's beautiful.
There's something beautiful in that.
When you really stop and look at the actual end,
the city like what is the end?
What's the end game is the end.
I mean what do you,
what do you really,
well,
I want to do it.
You want to leave behind some structures?
What do you want to go?
You want to want to have some things that are carved into stone.
What your name on it.
I'd like to build a monolith,
something very 2001 so something that looks like it was placed here by the
aliens.
Yeah.
What do you,
what do you want to do man?
What do you want to go?
Me?
No.
Anybody in the world,
you might as well go their way.
Their way seems great to get together with their little fucking country friends
at cocktail hour and start getting lit up and talk his shit and talk about all
the dicks.
They suck back in the old days.
I bet they do.
That's my grandma every afford drinks in.
They started talking about sucking cock crazy.
Maybe
I want it.
I want to hang out with grandma's getting wasted talking about sucking tick.
They're out there.
Awesome.
Does it.
We say it will be awesome until they get all fucking salivate and start looking
at your dances.
Weird.
That'd be weird.
That would be weird but awesome.
An old woman
used to be really hot and then you,
uh,
you see her now and you realize like,
Whoa,
like this is a strange,
like her body's deteriorated now.
She's just like little tiny thing that can barely get by.
Her back's all hunched over.
They used to be this soft,
supple,
juicy sex pot.
You know,
that's a weird thing.
The,
the recognition.
The recognition of mortality in that sense.
Yeah.
Sad.
Oh,
grandma's all young war stories.
You're talking about sucking Dick.
No.
Same War stories.
Old grandmas.
Well when you say war stories,
like what do you mean by wars and stories?
Yeah,
grandma's talking about that Shit,
man.
I hit all the dramatic angles.
Traumatic.
No,
I need to stop this podcast and get a fucking notepad.
Dramatic angles.
What and exactly.
Okay.
Hmm.
I'm trying to think of my head.
I guess it would be like the,
the Pov Angle.
There's a side angle.
Tangle retain it.
How do you suck Dick or looking at someone's taint?
No,
I'm saying she got to work this thing.
Grandma,
grandma got into the tank too.
They grew up in the fucking during the days were soap as expensive.
They probably didn't work that tank that they got up in there.
Do you think so?
I think during the depression there wasn't a lot of taint.
Look and we need to get a round table with these grandmothers and come to a
consensus on the craigslist freaky grandmas.
You fucks with the taint.
Come on.
The Joe Rogan,
any real grandmothers of Orlando have all these grandmas of Orlando that,
look,
we're sucking deck back in the fifties tell us what we hear from them.
Tell us what was up.
Grandma's telling us a serious crack beer.
Wow.
Teach these young kids to teach these young kids.
Um,
what are the disturbing shit?
Did you go see that?
You can freak us out about
Greenland melting.
And I'm training the Boston.
I don't know if we talked about it before.
It took us a while to shoot,
but I just,
uh,
we just finished it and it's fucked up during the Cold War.
Um,
you know,
right after sort of,
the first,
the first bomb of 45 that we started testing them and,
and you know,
what does it do?
And,
and so during the Cold War,
we had testing rounds in Nevada and all this shit.
The Soviets were doing these air,
uh,
tests,
you know,
to test,
air bursts.
And they did it in a place called the [inaudible],
uh,
testing polygon,
otherwise known as the polygon.
And in,
it was about an area that was inhabited by about 2 million people.
And so what happened is the majority,
we went there and we checked out the land and it was still a radiated.
Like 40 years later.
And it was,
I think the thing is like having five cat scans and hour 24 hours a day for the
rest of your life.
So all of these,
all of these towns around the polygon have these mutants,
right?
And like crazy mutants.
Like the scary thing about it actually is they had a whole orphanage of mutants
that looked exactly like the mutans from Akira.
Like maybe that's why they do or care of that way,
but like it was literally like a classic Comic Book Or Textbook,
like mutant and you're like,
it was scary because of that.
Like it wasn't like a,
you know,
it was a tumor here or whatever.
It was like these babies with these huge heads with veins and them and shit and,
and,
and not just one like,
you know,
a whole orphanage full of them.
There was this one guy who had his whole,
uh,
sort of,
you know,
all of his skin was like,
sort of looked like it was melting off was all tumors and you know,
that they have so many,
uh,
and this is three generations in.
So they're like,
okay,
what is this guy?
Not The guy.
That's one of the guys.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's sad man.
Yeah.
So,
so,
but anyways,
so what's happening now,
it's quite interesting because it's the x men,
but in real life is what's happening is the people from the Polygon,
I've gone into like other cities and stuff and their human genetics,
like their genome has been,
you know,
re configured by the radiation poisoning,
but they're passing it on sort of generation to generation.
So their kids and their kids' kids have these same sort of genetic disorders,
rare birth defects,
cancers,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so what they've started to argue for is that the issuance of a genetic
passport,
which registers your mutations and your human genes in your genome and the,
well,
the obvious sort of extension of that is why you fucking giving them a genetic
if you don't want them to procreate because you don't want them to procreate to
then pass on the mutated genome.
So it's this whole mute and versus norm kind of x men,
but in real life.
And you go,
wow,
that's Nazi-ism,
that's fucking eugenics.
That's fuck you that can't be,
and then you go and see the genetics that are been passed along and you're like,
oh,
this is some serious fucking shit.
We,
we did some.
And when I said,
we don't understand the technology,
obviously we don't understand the power of it.
We don't understand how to store it.
We don't understand how to make it without fucking melting down.
Fukushima's fucking irradiating fish in la.
Like it's crazy.
But when you talk about genetics and how genetics get affected,
you just get to the fucking tip of the iceberg.
I want shit,
we're fucking up.
And so when you see these people who are being issued by with genetic passports
to like you,
you know,
for procreation,
for all these things,
because their genome is fucked up.
You're like,
what the fuck we made that?
We did that.
We created this shit that fucks up our genetics.
It's crazy how bad his Fukushima
very bad.
Like,
like what,
what it shows,
what's interesting about it is,
so when sandy hit New York,
you know,
uh,
there's the 14th street power plant that,
that,
that got knocked out.
And it was like,
we have an 18 foot Floodwall like 18 feet,
man,
but what if the water comes over it?
But it can.
It's 18 feet.
But what if it comes up?
Well,
it will short out and we'll be fucked him.
There'll be no energy in fucking New York for that live on 14th street.
It happened
and the thing is,
and you sit there and you say,
okay,
but they're just incredulous because it can never go over the flood wall.
And then of course it did go to the flood wall,
blew up,
and then you'd fucking,
you have no power.
If you look at Fukushima,
it's a perfect example of the problem with nuclear power is that okay,
it's no way the fucking seat can come up here.
The sea can not come up.
It just can't get here.
Boom.
There's a fucking tsunami.
It comes up and it's fucking,
that's it.
Now the,
the,
the level of the levels of radiation have not fucking gone and they're still
worth,
we have a crew there shooting right now.
The levels of radiation in the area are through the fucking roof,
the levels of radiation now that go out and sort of concentric circles.
I think there's been some reports.
Now again,
I haven't verified these reports.
I'm going to go on the record of you know,
fish,
you know here that are fully,
you were radiated from Fukushima and you're like,
okay,
how much worse do we need it to be?
That's why you taking the spent fuel rods and things becomes an issue because we
can't go forward with the,
the,
the current,
the technology as it is.
And so that's why if you take the spent fuel and at least can do something with
it rather than just let it fucking irradiate for the next 10,000 and this has
all been proven,
this kid's theories,
you reusing splat fields?
Oh No,
not that.
I know.
Maybe they have,
I don't know.
I just saw a speech and I was,
you know,
I'd had a few drinks and I'm like,
I'm crying.
This guy is going to save my,
I love you.
17 year old boy with a bowl cut.
I did see a piece on the fish on a tune,
it's being 3% more irradiated than ever before.
That's a,
that's a big number.
3% after a couple of years when you do something that's going to be irradiating
the ocean for hundreds of thousands of years if it keeps leaking.
Yeah.
I mean,
is it,
you know,
that,
that thing that they're doing to where they're trying to make the structure to
keep all the water in all the radiated water.
Yeah.
And they're going to keep it in with ice wall so they didn't have to keep it
frozen.
And there's a lot of stories now coming out to the Japanese government,
you know,
kept it under wraps and didn't want to tell anybody in the food,
around in the whole region was a radiated people in Tokyo we're showing,
you know,
in increased,
uh,
signs,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And you're like,
well,
you know,
okay,
it's going to be bad for quite some time.
What do you expect him and how the fuck are they ever going to stop it?
I mean it's,
it's,
it's the rest of the world going to join in and help Japan.
Are they still leaving it up to Japan?
Like what's,
I think if you look,
but if you look at environmental things,
I mean now it's become such as this,
what is,
what's this?
Yeah.
That's not real though,
Jamie.
That's,
that's not,
uh,
that's the,
that's that's not what that represents.
Doesn't wrapper represent radiation?
A lot of people have mistakenly posted that things.
I don't know what it is,
but it's not radiation.
I remember reading it.
They really haven't mapped how much radiation is in there,
where it's going.
But one of the theories that I was,
I was listening to this,
a professor talk about the currents and the tides and where it's all going.
That somehow or another,
it's gonna wind up around Baja,
California and Mexico.
Yes.
It's being pushed out there.
Yeah.
And then it's going to pull up there because that's where everything from Japan
eventually go.
See what else?
This one area and pulls up and you're like,
that spot,
it's going to be dead.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why it's going to kill everything.
And that's of course a spot that a lot of people fish and a lot of people surf
and it's a very popular spot and it's just going to be radioactive as fuck and
it's going to go through the Polynesian islands before it gets there.
So pretty much everything is going to get raped.
It's unbelievably incredible that they never thought that it would be able to
get shut off,
that they just built this crazy power plant,
the ability to cool it down.
And that's what I'm saying is like we have these fail safe methods because
you're like,
well it can't.
Right.
Go above this.
And then it does because we,
you know,
now whether it's become fucking crazy.
Well it's also we,
first of all,
even if we,
whether wasn't becoming crazy,
those kinds of storms have existed throughout history.
It's incredibly arrogant and silly to assume that those storms won't exist
during the brief window of time that you haven't figured out how to shut these
plants down without it and you prepare for it because the one time it happens,
it's worth.
And also we've had earthquakes forever to like,
oh well here's a plant,
but if we have an earthquake,
we're fine.
Well you're going to have an earthquake.
Well they were good up until like a seven or something crazy like that.
They couldn't handle that 8.9 that rocked him.
Did you see that recent that was released
of the,
um,
this closed circuit camera,
the tsunami coming.
There's a car coming in.
The car sees a tsunami and turns around and leaves and you see the tsunami
literally chasing the car down the street.
It's so fucked.
Cause when you talk about like the water got to this guy's wheels before he
peeled out of there.
And then you see the waves with caring van houses behind him carrying houses.
And this guy's P and who knows if he made it.
I mean it would have been a cruel trick if were all applauding his escape.
And then he runs into a fucking traffic jam,
a block away and gets run over with a house.
But when you,
when you watch it,
it's pretty dark.
It's like,
Whoa,
that,
that shit came in quick caring houses.
Damn.
Yeah.
And that could happen here.
Well,
it's a fault.
it's not just a fault.
There's assholes that have,
look at this.
This is a,
this isn't the video,
but this is one video of how quick it overcomes everything.
Look at that.
A dry city.
And then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
here comes,
oh shit.
You better turn around bitches.
Look at this.
Whew.
Oh,
look at this job.
This guy,
oh my God,
look at,
but it's coming in with houses.
Yeah.
Not One house houses like hundreds of houses in Wood.
It's just fucking insane.
Okay.
And it's happened here.
It's happened here throughout history.
There was a big one apparently somewhere,
I think they said it was the 17 hundreds,
uh,
in Portland somewhere allow around Portland.
They just wiped out.
Most of the Pacific northwest just came in a couple of hundred miles and it
fucking killed everything and pulled out and every,
and you know,
a couple hundred years later,
trees grow back and everything looks nice.
No,
it's fine if that happens.
If there's not a reactor there,
if there's a reactor there,
it's pulling out all that radioactive material forever.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well you mean,
yeah,
you're right.
I mean that's the scariest thing is when it's happening somewhere near reactor.
What really scared me is that I don't,
I don't think I've heard one person come up with any way that makes sense as to
how to contain it.
Not just how to contain it,
but how to stop it.
How to clean the area up is almost just not even discussed.
Right.
I mean how the fuck do they clean that?
How do you put,
you're going to put a giant filter on the ocean.
I'm guessing they can't and that's why they don't talk about it,
but that's no reason either.
It's not going to fuck up the entire west coast cause that's like the worst case
doomsday scenarios that I've read online that entire west coast for sure out
there with the radiation moving to California at that shit is,
that map is scary.
Let's what I said that map doesn't necessarily represent radiation.
Yeah.
Well,
let me say radiation map,
Japan debunked.
I'll pull it up because,
okay.
You kinda are good at sort of putting some up and then debunking
it.
That's what it is.
I'm mysterious,
Bro.
I move around.
Yeah.
Debunking the NC a radiation map.
More Fukushima skier scaremongering debunked.
Yes.
Apparently
not.
What,
how do you know that the debunking isn't the moment?
Tell them to him,
dude,
you're scaring the fuck out of me now.
I don't even know.
Um,
no,
no.
Uh,
yeah.
Apparently it's been debunked.
A couple of different websites that seems to make sense.
Snopes,
Snopes debunked it.
Image purportedly shows radioactive sewage spreading across the Pacific Ocean
and is false.
That's not what it is.
But how do you know that the person is saying that isn't true?
It's true.
If you want to be all crazy doom and gloom,
but me,
I want to live my life.
Um,
so we've really vacillated tonight between doom and gloom and fuck it.
It's all right.
It's going to be okay.
Then I'm like,
you know what?
It is going to be okay in here know sort of Meth head guy with the radioactive
isotopes.
Someone who is an immigrant in America I would think you would respect are fine
country enough to that.
You would look on the bright side of things.
The glass is half full.
Shane Smith of vice.com captain doom and gloom.
So you pay your mortgage on doom and gloom.
How dare you.
And my fine country,
I smile in my show.
If the shit hits the fan,
you're going to move to Montreal?
No it gets warmer.
Nice up there.
But Canadian Shield,
you know get up there and the lakes,
millions of lakes can't get to me.
Can't get to me moving fast.
Is that well you don't have to worry about
people.
What I'm saying the shit hits the fan.
I'm saying when you have to like build a house out of logs and go trapping from
beavers for dinner and it's Canadian shoe man.
It's a good spot up there plus of global warming.
We get to those going to be like the road for like a thousand miles just with
your shopping cart dog.
Shit and shit.
Dog sled dogs.
Yeah.
You need a dog sled
dogs.
No,
that's why I'm enjoying the shit out of my shit because God knows how much
longer we got.
So enjoy it.
You have an extra potent doom and gloom,
uh,
ideology in your head or,
or vision in your head rather because you're doing so much traveling.
So many fucked up spots.
Like if you were just traveling to the United States and Canada,
you might be like a lot of folks that are out there that are just like,
yeah,
everything's gonna be fine.
Yeah.
We were talking earlier about the,
the 34,000 foot sort of uh,
how uh,
how it changes your shit.
Like you can become more emotional or whatever.
It was interesting will explain that for the people didn't,
weren't listening at like high altitude,
long haul.
You get this lights.
Yeah.
Like 34,000 pieces of cruising,
flight of general commercial aviation.
And so there's a syndrome where you feel emotions much stronger.
So if you're like watching a movie for example,
and I was to that on
the movie Armageddon,
I was like bawling my eyes out.
You just,
you have this uncontrollable like,
oh my God,
he's going to marry Liv Tyler or whatever.
And uh,
and,
but you know,
normally it wouldn't be like,
but you can also feel a euphoric.
You can feel sad,
you can like,
it's just a sort of emotion crank,
you know,
at,
at high altitudes.
Um,
what were we talking about?
Well,
you were talking about emotions,
emotions,
fine.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right?
So when I come back on playing,
sometimes I have these emotional things and I'm like,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm going to get a place in the Canadian shield.
I'm going to get a place,
just hedge my bets.
Just maybe shit doesn't go wrong,
but I always say this,
if you notice there's a 1% chance or a 5% chance,
you didn't hedge your bets,
you're a fucking idiot.
So I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to hedge my bet.
I'm going to get a place up in the Canadian shield with a freshwater lake and no
one can get to.
It's hard to get to all this shit and now you're going to build a fucking
cottage on there.
You can have a cottage during the summers.
And by the way,
if a shit goes bad,
you're up there,
you got water,
you got all shit.
Okay,
fine.
Now I thought this was a particular sort of lunacy of my 34,000 foot fly back
from carpooled to fucking cheeseburger land.
And then I started talking to people,
right,
who are like running media companies or journalists or run the bureau out of
the,
you know,
uh,
Qubole or you know,
just,
you know,
people who have been sort of around the world are doing every single fucking one
of them is like,
I'm going to bolt hole.
Yeah,
I got a place in the mountains here.
I got a place over here.
I got a place over there.
And I think it's because you realize it probably won't happen,
but,
and it shouldn't happen.
And people thought at the end of the world was coming for a long time and,
and I'm the least sort of,
you know,
conspiracy theory,
oh,
we're all going to die kind of guy and all this shit.
And I'm like,
if it hasn't happened before now and then however you go to enough things like
Fukushima or like Greenland or like Dagestan or Pakistan or all these,
Pakistan by the way,
is becoming a failed state.
It has fucking over a hundred warheads on ms child's ready to fucking go.
So at a certain point you're just like,
I'm a gambling man.
I'm going to hedge my bets.
I'm going to fucking just have a bolt hole because if shit goes down,
why the fuck wouldn't you?
Yeah.
And,
and I didn't think it affected me until I had that discussion.
It was one of those things where it's like,
I masturbate.
Yeah.
So do I.
So do I,
you know,
it's like everybody admitted to we,
we have this sort of paranoia and they were all,
it was kind of like mine to do.
And I was like,
Oh fuck,
it's fucked me up now.
And then I felt like I have a fucked up,
huh?
Yeah.
When you travel it's hard to deny or turn an eye to the things that you see
going on in the conditions that are in other places.
And like we are fed the illest Soma here in America.
We get the best Soma and I think it really,
really blinds us to what's going on and what could happen to us.
When you say Sama,
you don't mean the sleeping pills,
the brave new world.
Aldous Huxley,
like right.
You know,
the wool over our eyes.
Like we have television,
we have memes,
we have,
you know,
all these things that distract us.
We have cheap food,
we have cheap real estate,
we have cheap loans,
you know,
and,
and so I think it distracts us from the fact that like these problems that are
at the water's edge could be at your door very quickly.
And you see it like Detroit I think is the latest example.
Hmm.
Detroit as a scary example,
we were there filming and there were houses for sell for $500 you buy a house
for 500 bucks.
We did a story there that I fucking,
I'm sorry I didn't,
no,
I was going to say,
and the smell in the air is insane.
The pollution is so tangible and you feel,
we have this great story of these uh,
uh,
kids,
you know,
and they're scrappers and they go into these houses that are abandoned houses
and they rip every piece of metal out of it,
right?
And then they sell it to these,
uh,
um,
barges and the barges come in and they fill them with all this crap.
And all the schools,
all the old hospitals,
they're just ripping all the metal out,
all the girders,
everything.
And they ship it to China because the quest for steel is insatiable.
So,
and we founded in Baltimore,
we did it in Cleveland,
we did in Detroit where we're ripping the shit out of our old industrial cities
and literally melting it down to do the new industrial cities in China.
It's so organic.
It is.
Right.
I was like,
that's kind of a poetic story actually were pulling down our shit,
melting it and then building it for the,
for what they did with the,
all the record.
David Shosha shot that for really?
David Cho is the host of that and he goes out with the kids as they,
as they,
they,
they rip these buildings every fucking like big industrial schools and she had
factories and they just take all the fucking didn't,
that's,
that's so crazy.
Who didn't that isn't that what they did with the,
with the twin towers when they fell as well?
Didn't they sell the scrap to China?
Oh,
I don't know.
That's interesting.
I'm pretty sure they did.
I'm pretty sure they a box it all up and ship that North Korea,
when you go around North Korea,
all the buildings have like all these big,
like they looked like they,
uh,
concrete woodpecker has packed away at them cause they pull out the rebar and
then they sell the rebar to China's scrap and you're like,
wow,
hold on.
You're going to make your whole fucking,
I mean,
how much money can you get for that much rebar?
Like 500 bucks,
get the contact.
Do you know what I mean?
Like if you're stealing,
if you're a scrapper and Detroit,
how did you get in touch with people that melt this down and then sell it to
China?
No,
no,
because China's buying essentially all the scrap.
They have such a desire for steel and steel is expensive and hard to me.
So to get scrapped and then melted down is actually more cost efficient.
Even shipping it across the world.
So what they're doing is not just in America,
there are anywhere where they can send scrap.
The open order is send it here.
It's not just get Detroit's,
you know,
schools and give them,
to me it's,
it's,
you know,
they're just taking all the scrap from everywhere.
Yeah,
there's a demand and then it filters down Zachary Hood.
Wow.
What's that?
So it's such a weird and ironic twist to our store,
isn't it?
What a poetic fucking,
we sold off our manufacturing overseas to the WTO and all the different bills
they pass that cut out the manufacturing base in this country,
and then they slowly extract the metal and ship it into the over to.
We're living off the sort of remnants of that society and we're like taking
everything and going salad salad.
So weird.
You know,
Detroit has started to make a comeback as far as cars at least.
Yeah.
At least American cars,
they started producing real cars again,
like Cadillac one,
the car the year motor trend car of the year.
Yeah,
the CTS V it's a fucking bad ass car.
It's a technological marvel.
It handles as good as any German car that's ever been made.
The build quality spectacular they have.
They're actually making real cars.
The new corvette or the new Corvettes.
Amazing.
It's an amazing car.
They're making cars that people want to buy,
like finally,
but God damn,
they fucked it up for a long time.
You remember from the 70s until like today,
American cars were a joke.
If you weren't buying a Ford pickup truck,
those really solid as a rock Chevy pickup trucks,
like things along those lines.
Most of American cars were dog shit.
Yeah.
What was quality control talk shit.
You have to give a shit.
And the thing is is Japanese people I ended up started lunch really were like
give a shit.
Yeah.
Their culture,
their,
they're missing all the fucking crucial elements that make,
every American thinks that he's awesome individually,
so much so that they're not willing to succeed to the group.
You know,
in Japan,
like it's a big part of working at a factory is that everything is for the
company.
Everything for company and they,
you know,
they take pride in the fact that the company does well also,
if you go to any like,
you know,
shitty five o'clock fucking drunk ramen place,
they'd been boiling that stock for two days and everything's perfect.
You go to a Shitty Yakitori place.
It's like they've met the make it the best they possibly fucking can.
And it's like they give a shit.
If I'm going to make fucking Yakitori,
it's going to be the best.
God Damn Yakitori I can possibly,
yeah,
we got this entitled attitude in this country or I shouldn't say we.
Some people have this,
it's a poison of character.
Sure.
And it's a great fucking Yakitori fuck it.
I'm going to make it shit.
And you're like,
well hold on if you're going to fucking do it.
But he has anything to do anything.
Yeah.
Shane pointed out the Ramen Yakitori it makes sense because there's a lot of
chefs that get a lot of a claim in this country simply for the fact that they
speak English because they can communicate it better.
They have the money to open a Yaki Tory place in the right neighborhood where
writers live where it's accessible,
but they usually,
it's not about authentic or whatever.
It's exactly what you talked about is the person from that culture probably
gives a shit more because it them
in a lot of people like young chefs and things like that,
they think that they can go over to someplace for a couple of weeks and be like,
oh,
I can make yagats where I can make ramen this.
This is easy stuff.
You know,
like that Guy Ivan Ramen,
he's very,
very famous.
He did ramen in Japan,
but he lived that shit.
You know,
you really have to lie.
He named himself after the soup.
Yeah.
Or he was lame that anyway.
And he became,
because he was,
I'm not sure,
he opened a place in New York.
It's like all the buzz.
I haven't been yet.
Nice guy.
Met Him.
If his name was Ivan Ramen,
then it would be interesting to find out if because of his name he became Mr
Ramen or if,
because,
just because I just think his restaurant was named,
I'm not sure.
Did you ever see that one?
And um,
Tony Robbins special,
um,
where he went to not Tony Robbins.
Tony Bourdain's,
Jesus Christ.
Where you have seen the Tony Robbins one.
I feel fuck Tony Robbins noodle special.
And there was this one dude who was,
had been making noodles the same way his family had been making noodles for
fucking,
you know,
how many things popping up was out sick.
Wasn't that amazing?
Yeah.
I mean,
watch this guy make noodles all fucking day.
Press it.
Make any,
see what physical labor it is.
Yeah,
and this guy is just a master and make noodles and I never considered that there
was an art to making noodles
that here.
Like if some kid from Culinary Institute of America,
I hang out with these other shifts.
If somebody was doing that here,
he'd put that guy in a glass case in the front of his restaurant where a chef
coat and be like,
give me awards.
I deserve it.
Do you see what I'm doing?
It's like,
dude,
chill.
You know you should do it because that's,
that's a good side chef talk a lot of people mad about people wanting to awards.
I'm the Kanye West.
The chefs,
no,
I don't even submit to those things.
I had met these sites,
Julia Child Bitch.
That shit is funny.
Was going to step up and give me the [inaudible] money to one my new fast food
joint.
Who's the best chef in the world?
I think that's,
I don't think that's Dario say.
Go.
Do you ask her?
She'll know what question I could answer.
I can't answer like who's the best chef in the world?
I think there's no answer that I will say that there's one set I met that I
would bet I do bowel too in the,
I'm like his fucking grasshopper and when I see him he inspires me and I just
want to be a fly on the wall in his kitchen and hanging out with him.
He's the best master.
You incestuous and he's been featured in like Fuchsia Dunlop.
I'm going to say Emeril.
Emeril is also the man.
Damn,
I met Emeril.
Emeril.
Emeril is a stand
up dude.
Really cool,
really cool down our through to really knows his food.
But master you in Chengdu.
I met,
cooked me some of the best meals I've ever seen.
And then he also kind of showed me new techniques on dishes that I'd been
cooking for years.
Right.
And,
and that's dope.
When somebody can take something you've been doing for so long and be like,
check it out this way.
Like what was the,
in the variations,
what were the dish that he cooked for you?
All right.
So the simplest thing was the most impressive thing that he taught me was Chili
Oil,
right?
People will always have an issue with temperature and making Chili oil to get it
at the right temperature and use the thermometer and things like that.
Chili oil,
what he does is he heats up his oil to a certain point where canola oil will be
a little yellow at first.
He'll heat heated up so hot that it becomes white,
let the temperature drop.
Then he'll heat it up till it's hot to the touch and put it over the chili
grounds,
and that'll be like an encasing so that when he puts hotter oil on top,
it won't burn the Chili Oil.
So he'll cook it in a,
in an oil that's just slightly hot to touch.
Then he'll heat it up another 60 degrees or something,
put more of that oil and then he'll get it ripping hot and put that oil in,
but the Chili never burns.
And then you can also see how the flavor of the chilies and the smell of the
Chili's changes at every temperature.
And that is the hallmark of session one.
Cooking.
That is the thing that's most amazing.
They took a couple ingredients but one especially is the red dried chili pepper
and just because of temperature.
Yes.
Hold on Brian.
I need to feel the energy just because the temperature just because of
temperature,
that one ingredient can become so many different things and it's like that,
that culture of cooking sesh,
one cooking in China pays that much attention to almost every ingredient
available to them,
but us now like our culinary revolution,
so to speak in America is such a like pho revolution to me like in other like
France,
you go to France,
you go to China,
there's people been cooking and doing these things for 5,000 years and this is
what their parents teach them in their homes.
It's really cool.
Sorry.
Wow,
that's fascinating shit man.
The idea deer that they've figured out how to not overheated.
That's,
yeah,
and that's why I don't like read the food blogs here,
but I will travel and are go into any place and I want to see like your,
your technique.
Like,
that's what I'm looking for.
I don't care about like fancy restaurants or ambiance.
I want to see technique and it's really fun to see someone takes something so
simple that's available to you everyday.
It's,
it's a walk.
It's oil and it's a dry chili pepper.
You can fuck with it all day.
Sorry,
I just wanted to ask him a question because I love such one.
And I love Chili.
I'm a Columbia,
Chile fanatic and uh,
uh,
I'm Irish.
So,
uh,
what,
what Chile,
Chile does to me.
What,
what a beef does to you.
But I'm addicted to it.
I love Chili or all different kinds of Chili,
but I love session.
But I,
it was only when I went there that I realized they have to spices.
They have chili and Mung and I never had it before going to China.
I think it's illegal actually to do here maybe.
But you know,
in China and in session one dishes,
there's tons and tons
of monk.
Do you know what Hmong is?
No.
It's a spice that they put in the dels don't numbs your mouth.
Your tongue.
You mean like peppercorn?
Yeah,
yeah,
they have it here.
We just have dried session on peppercorn mostly available.
Some restaurants can get green pepper corn,
but the green pepper corn,
it's like eating a Newport cigarette.
It's kind of amazing.
I love
eating a Newport cigarette.
Calms your mouth.
Yeah.
Numbs your tongue.
It numbs your whole fucking shit.
It's amazing.
Now let me ask you this,
cause I don't understand chilies or peppers.
Why in New Mexico?
Why is New Mexico famous for Chili's?
Hatch Green Chiles.
What is the deal?
It's native to them and Chihuahua.
Yeah,
but you can go screen breast screen her.
They'll like,
they cook them for you and they'll,
they'll freeze them and ship them to you and they're worth getting from New
Mexico.
Oh yes.
It's really cool.
Those reasons,
like New Orleans has the creole tomato that's only available for about like six
weeks out of the year and it's almost like a fruit tomato.
Then you have like the hatch green chilies in New Mexico,
like America has this amazing produce that's native to the country and it's cool
to go on the ground to these regions where they've played with it for hundreds
of years.
The hatch green shows,
what they were saying was that it was just not,
it's not a super spicy Chili.
It's delicious.
Tastes delicious.
Yeah.
We were shooting that Mitt Romney or not Mitt Romney,
Romney,
the Mormon colonies in Chihuahua and we were there like a couple of weeks and I
was just going,
what the fuck is,
this shit is awesome and it's the Hash Green Chili or Hatch Green Chili Salt,
which is the best shit I've ever had and it's an,
it's an Amit to a Chihuahua was like the meat,
you know,
and so they have stakes and they have a shit and you have a barbecue steak and
they just pour this,
this,
this chili on top.
It's the best fucking thing
in New Mexico.
They use it with antelope.
They have a lot of antelope pronghorn antelopes in New Mexico and they cook it.
That's where I saw these Chili's.
It was on the show meat eater.
They shot an antelope and then they,
uh,
they cooked it with a,
these chilies New Mexico style and they do,
we'll just raving about how good these chilies off shows are.
Fantastic.
I've got to get some of that shit.
I'm going to get some of you,
if you,
if you know the place,
I'm going to get some because I fucking love that.
All right,
well let's see.
How long you in town for ever in La for this?
I'm living with you now.
All right.
Okay.
We'll figure it out.
Moving to the commune.
Isn't that why you invited us here?
We're here.
We're queer.
And I brought my,
uh,
Nike's and my,
we don't need Nike's man,
Nike of bad record.
We need a,
we're going to go with converse all stars because they're weird.
That's a weird one.
Eight,
six is it gives you like an athletic air.
Like what am I wrestler?
Sounds weird.
Um,
I wanted to talk to you about that.
I had a funny conversation with Jimmy Kimmel today,
uh,
about that drug that you guys covered on vice.
That devil's watching.
[inaudible] pulling scopolamine
means the same shit that they put in the patch to they give to people when
they're seasick.
My doctor told me that's Cupola mean is like regularly prescribed for people
that have sea sick when they have the path
in the different dosages.
Like basically what this cupola mean,
that is the,
is the Zombie drug is like the heroin level alkaloid,
you know what I mean?
And then this could pull the mean in the patches like the aspirin.
Well that's because,
uh,
the,
the reason why I was bringing this up is a Jimmy Kimmel was telling me that him
and Adam Carolla had the patches on and they had a couple of beers and they
allegedly might've been around someone else who was smoking illegal marijuana.
They would not have partaken in of themselves.
Maybe they did,
but,
uh,
he said it was like he was living inside of a tin box.
He said he was fucked up and then totally new,
kind of fucked up.
Which makes sense.
If you've got this fucking devil's breath,
Columbia,
this is what's called the Colombians.
Devil's breath.
Yeah.
That spike.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the vice piece on that is incredible.
If you haven't seen it,
world's scariest drug.
Uh,
it's called Columbian Devil's breath and it's on vice and vice is,
if you don't know the greatest online source of fascinating documentaries,
expos,
A's interview is,
there's nothing better and it's all because of this motherfucker.
Holla Atcha boy la.
But this,
uh,
Colombians,
devil's breath shit is fucking terrifying because they give it to people and
then the people just do your bidding.
They have no idea.
It's amazing.
It's really amazing.
You watch it in,
in person.
No.
Uh,
I've seen the video,
I've seen the footage.
I didn't do the shoot,
but the,
they,
the,
a lot of how it works is prostitutes put these nose plugs up their nose and they
have like a condom or a balloon with some in it and they put in their mouth.
And then what they do is,
is,
is when you go close,
they sort of blow it into your face and it's a ton of it.
And then,
but they have the like,
um,
a security camera footage of like people clearing out the all,
they're a furniture in their house or people going to the bank machine and just
taking all their money out.
Um,
and because it's auto suggestive,
so you're in this sort of like trance like state and you're like,
now do this and you know,
okay,
and I'll take my money out now open your door.
And so they,
you know,
it's,
uh,
apparently this I haven't verified,
but the Tonton Macoute the,
uh,
the,
um,
sort of a Zombie police in,
uh,
in Haiti for the,
for those years under Papa Doc,
we're like,
that was cupola.
I mean,
that was the Zombie drug.
They call the Zombie Drug Devil's breath.
It's got different names everywhere,
but it's like this auto suggestive drug.
What a strange side effect or effect of his,
that's crazy.
It's crazy.
And this stuff is apparently very prevalent.
I mean,
it,
it grows wild,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
it grows in America.
It's,
it's a sort of making,
it's like making a poppy into heroine.
It's the same sort of
process of making an alkaloid,
but it's incredible that it's the same stuff that they use for sleep or for a
seasickness.
Yeah.
Someone told me and other thing that it was in,
it was a,
it was,
um,
a part of,
you know,
famous like,
I know Viagra,
so I'm sort of famous drug that everybody has parts Cupola mean.
So it's just in what is the,
what's the dosage?
That's all it is.
Yeah,
exactly.
This is incredible that that's cupola mean.
Like if you look at prevent motion sickness,
transderm sculpt,
it's actually,
maybe it's motion sickness.
Maybe that was it.
Yeah.
Trends.
DERMS scope.com.
Well,
seasickness his motion sickness.
I'm pretty sure it's exactly the same thing,
but that's amazing that it's done devil's press shit.
Well,
according to Jimmy Kimmel,
do not take that with beer and we'd,
cause it's,
it's a fucking bad,
it's a bad ride.
Bad ride inside the tin can.
And we could've tried the auto suggestive powers of it.
Yeah.
I wonder if that me,
maybe he did some terrible things and he doesn't even know.
Maybe someone had him.
It's very strange that those two things are are related in that I guess you
could just cover someone with those patches while they're asleep to start
sticking them all over their body and then they wake up and you're like,
bitch,
I own you.
It's time to go to the ATM.
It's do it.
Wake up.
I wonder if that's ever been attempted.
Wonder if I'm fucking up because I suggested it and no one ever thought of it
before.
Now it's going to be a thing.
Somebody be out.
It has to be the first person you go to the am pm covered in patches.
Yeah.
There's no way I can be all your fucking Twizzlers.
I shouldn't have told people that.
That's the same thing I fucked up.
Hey,
what do I do now?
How do I get out of the tremendous knowledge comes tremendous power and
responsibility.
Okay,
well what if you have almost no knowledge but Wikipedia?
How much responsibilities and when you're just Google searching shit,
is there a lot of on the line there?
How much do I owe
you?
Good.
It's going to have a great time and give away all his money.
You guys went with Dennis Rodman to fucking North Korea.
Um,
what the fuck was that?
Has that happening and how the fuck is Dennis Rodman going back after home?
He just killed his uncle.
Yeah.
Well he's,
well,
you know,
look,
it's resurrected.
His career.
You know Dennis Rodman's has it.
Really?
What is it?
What kind of career does that resurrect?
He's a basketball player.
What is,
what is the career now dude?
I saw them sponsoring restaurants.
Barbecue restaurant.
Yeah,
totally got me,
dude.
Oh,
that's funny.
You would fucking salad
reading Asian stereotypes and just fake news.
The idea that all of a sudden Dennis Rodman is huge in the agent community and
he just fucking sell on everything.
They have Fox News.
Dude,
I just make shit up.
This it,
this is it.
And this is him in North Korea.
Wow.
That is so fucking Uber strange man.
Well.
Okay,
tell me,
this was your second time there,
right?
This is after you guys had filmed that one piece that was exposing all the
weirdness about their restaurants and all that other shit.
Right.
Same time or no,
no.
Twice and did documentaries and because I had been there,
I knew that they were crazy about a basketball,
but be the Chicago Bulls.
I can't go back because of my previous two documentaries,
but we knew that they love the Chicago Bulls.
So we tried to put them together again to go do a tour.
But no one would except for Rodman who is signing bay basketball cards in Denver
or something.
And so he,
yeah,
he said,
I'll go and,
and,
and obviously we need more people than just him.
So the globe trotters a agreed to go,
but we thought we didn't know he would show up.
We didn't know.
Like we thought like this would just be a way to get in and see some different
shit.
And then Kim Jong Goon showed up and then not only showed up,
said,
hey,
come back to my house.
And everyone went back to his house and got absolutely loaded and you know,
talk to a bunch of,
is he the only one that's allowed to wear that haircut in North Korea?
Like what if somebody else wanted to rock that crazy haircut that Kim,
Jon Owen has theirs.
There's actually only seven haircuts that are allowed by the state and they have
to be done in a particular way like his haircut.
But pause that like back then Jamie Bam,
look at that haircut.
Yeah,
no,
that would be a,
that would be a haircut.
Is that only,
you know what's interesting?
So he looks the,
one of the reasons why they picked him because uh,
Kim Jong Il had a bunch of sons cause he had a bunch of lovers,
whatever.
And this kid,
they weren't going to uh,
pick because he was educated in Switzerland and that's the back of west.
It's about,
but he had an older son who was picked up in like a Tokyo,
which is an a,
you just can't do that.
And another son that smashed a Ferrari and like Monaco and,
and you know,
in the poorest country in the world and they're fucking smashing Ferrari's
Monaco.
But he,
the,
one of the reasons why he got in is because he looks exactly like his
grandfather,
Kim Il Sung,
who was the founder.
Like he was the,
the first of the,
he was drained by the Soviets and then he came down and he started the whole,
uh,
you know,
a cult of personality.
The original,
the original,
the original cumulus song.
And he looked so much like him that it's like,
it's like me being born looking exactly like Abe Lincoln.
They're just like this,
but he's the,
just put them up there and so that,
that's why they put them up there and now he's,
he's now he's purging the shit out of people.
It's probably not him purging the shit out of people.
It's the generals behind him getting rid of the other generals that oppose.
So these are the generals that were loyal to the previous administration,
his father's administration,
and they've criticized him.
Is that what it is?
No,
I think the uncle,
it has his own power sort of thing.
And so,
oh no.
So this is them getting rid of,
you know the,
the,
the dowager sorta uncle talked
a little too much.
Shit.
Got a little too conti.
Disrespectful gold.
This was perfectly yourself.
Go a little out of line yourself.
Let alone yourself.
I remember the scene.
Fucking Joe Pesci kills the guy got a little out of and stuff and Robert De Niro
and him stopped the guy to death.
Yes.
Kate,
you shine box.
Remember that Guy Billy Bathgate?
Yup.
Billy battery go.
Yeah.
So he killed the fire.
They killed the uncle and then hired though the wife of the uncle gave her a new
position.
Yeah.
Although I read something recently about the wife that now that's she,
she's been detained or you know,
something.
I didn't see that something's happening.
Well,
I had also read that maybe the wife had a,
played a part in it,
that she was trying to get rid of him.
He was a fucking,
he was tired of her husband trying to stick it in her butt or something.
I mean,
Kerry gave like a crazy interview about it to where he was just opened the
talking about how he's killing off people and,
and how it's making him nervous.
And it was interesting to see a diplomat just go
balls to the wall with it.
I was like,
well,
remember when Carrie was like fucking sounding the war horns for Syria and the
entire government,
the entire country was like,
um,
no,
like no one,
not Fox News,
not CNN,
not fucking anybody was like,
this is a good move for America.
We need to go to war was here.
Everybody was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
We need to go with a Russian Syria,
Russia on one side,
us on there.
Well,
we've seen where this ends up.
Is that one of the first times you've seen in your lifetime where the United
States,
the people literally said,
fuck this.
And the government backed off.
Well,
for sure.
And it was such a black eye because actually Putin said,
oh,
I'll,
I'll negotiate this plank because they're backing Assad and we were going to
back the other side.
So it's a cold war fight again.
And Putin comes up with a peace plan and we were so embarrassed that we went,
yeah,
okay,
we'll take your peace plan.
We'll take rush this bs plan who we were about to go to war.
He seems so reasonable.
And the,
and the peace plan too,
it's like,
yeah,
get that guy who essentially the,
the czar of Russia is more reasonable.
Yeah.
Well you just got back from there.
One of the most unfriendly.
It has to be unfriendly and anti American.
Like what's interesting is that you would think that the cold war never ended
because you go there and the anti American anti-western rhetoric is crazy and
they blame everything.
Russia's economic problems that the American's fucking financial crisis,
you know this thing.
Well that's the American spending too much on the arms race.
Oh,
the problem with the gas going into Europe.
That's the American's flooding the shit with all their fucking gas and the
racism's over over.
Yeah.
When was the last time you went to Russia?
I was there three months ago.
I was probably there right before you were there.
And um,
no,
it was not a happy
place.
You get off there you go on the train.
I took the train around there,
man.
It's a,
it's a depressing place.
It's pretty sad.
What am I went there to film a film,
film,
a movie and he got hit in the face of the metal pipe.
They hit him in the teeth with a metal pipe,
smashed all the CT,
woke up with a mouth full of blood and broken teeth.
All of his mind's messing shoes.
He doesn't know who the fuck it was.
He turned the corner and someone just fucking faced him with a pipe.
It's a violent place.
Cops,
cops shake people down there on the regular civilians.
The cops will shake them down.
Yeah,
man,
that's a dark place.
That's a dark place that's lost a lot of its sons as well.
You a lot of beautiful women there that are growing up hard.
A lot of liver stealers.
You know what I'm saying?
Wake up with stitches.
All groggy.
Connected to an ivy.
Yeah.
No,
you get that feeling out there man.
Like as an American,
it's not a,
it's not a friendly place.
Hostel Type Shit.
Hostile as in hostile,
the fucking movie where they steal your liver.
I don't want that.
Or they just tortured people and killed them or something.
Yeah,
it seems hostile,
which is why it's so scary to think about going to war with a hardened people
that were controlled by the Mongols for over 200 years.
The Mongols came,
I mean everybody tried to conquer Russia.
Napoleon lost 60% of his troops trying and the Mongols came in there in the
winter.
They came in in the winter and fucked everybody up and just dominated the whole
country for a couple hundred years.
Yeah,
dude,
Mongolia,
Mongolia is the most magical place I have been this year.
Magical.
It's,
it's very cool because there are parts of it that remain untouched.
You walked far enough,
you drive far enough into the desert.
There are places where just like,
man,
I feel like original man,
well these people don't know the size of the step,
the size of the steps of Mongolia.
The step meaning the,
it's the area of like sort of like a,
an an ocean with all the water taken out of it is twice as big as the Atlantic
Ocean,
twice as wide as the Atlantic Ocean and it's just this flat plane and that's
where we're Gingiss Khan was Bert,
you ever see the movie Mongol?
Yeah.
It's a good movie.
But the funny thing is,
well not funny.
Mongolians don't like that move.
Really?
Yeah,
there's another gang is con movie coming out,
but they feel like they weren't depicted properly in the movie mom.
Well they should be happy.
They got John Wayne to play gangs con the original,
cause he fucking knocked it out of the park.
That shit was authentic is fuck you ever see John Wayne and Kingus Khan and one
of the worst pieces of American film or culture period.
It's dark diggity dog shit sounds bad.
The best thing on the Mongols,
without a doubt,
I say this all the time,
but if you haven't heard it,
Dan Carlin's hardcore history,
wrath of the con.
It's a five part series,
five two plus hour long podcast on the Mongols and it's fucking magical.
It's amazing.
Just the sheer numbers that he drops on you.
The Mongols killed many fucking people.
They killed 11% of the entire population of the earth.
Wow.
Yeah.
One out of every 500 dudes in China is related to gangs con.
Wow.
Yeah.
Directly.
I did that DNA online.
My brother did the DNA online test and like we have DNA from there obviously.
Damn,
you got conned DNA.
What they'll say is your DNA comes from this region and like it was Mongolia or
Korea,
you know,
so.
Right.
The interesting thing though is this,
when you go to an old country,
an old culture like Mongolian culture it,
the wisdom has been passed down.
Like you see these things,
people have this like patients about them and they,
I was in the desert and I was talking to these people is booked,
the minds are coming,
the mines are threatening your way of life.
Are you worried that like there will be no nomads in the next generation?
And they're like,
yeah,
we're worried about it.
We,
we know that like this way of life is going by the wayside,
but we've persevered.
We've been through a lot.
We've seen a lot of things like our people have always persevered and it's
interesting too,
they have this confidence in that because it's such an old culture,
it's such an old culture and at one point in time,
such an incredibly dominant culture.
Very proud of it.
They're really,
they have gang is counting their money.
Yeah.
This is the guy killed in his lifetime.
Five zero million,
right between the low numbers are 20 the high number is like 70 wow.
And a lot of people say somewhere between 40 and 50 million people with horses
and bows and arrows,
they killed everybody.
It's unbelievable.
How much damage this one guy,
this is John Wayne is gang Chi.
You got to hear him talk because it's goofy as fuck.
Oh
really?
Your night with me?
He didn't even try to have a correct accent.
No.
Nor did he do.
What would they always do?
And movies where they're speaking a language that nobody else speaks where they
go with a British accent.
Right.
Was just always a good move.
I mean,
he looked like he,
man,
that shit was terrible that she was like,
the rifle man goes to Mongol.
He's fucking stupid old movies man.
It's like a James Bond where he has to become Japanese to get on the island.
Yeah.
And it's just like so bad and they're all like,
Yep,
he's Jeff,
uh,
Tom Cruise.
Why that stuff is just goofy.
Molly's Tom Cruise played a white guy,
white guy,
but still I was like,
man,
it's the last song.
Ryan,
the last guy that lives is Tom fucking food.
It has to be a white guy.
I was going to be the last one.
Well,
he's not just a white guy.
He's got more alien in him than anybody else.
Not only that,
if there's an accident,
he has to stop because only he knows what to do because he's a,
you're just
an sp.
Have you ever seen that speech?
No.
Well,
he gives in front of the science.
It's fucking beautiful.
He's,
it's a Scientology recruitment speech and he's talking about as when you're a
Scientologists,
like you know that if you pass by an accident and you're the one who needs to
stop,
you need your,
you're positive.
You're,
you've got that fucking Scientology energy worker for you.
You got to get everyone else's an sp,
so you've got to get in.
What's an sp again?
Suppressive personality.
That's me,
dawg.
I'm all about suppressing.
Can't just let it go.
Can't just let it loose.
I've got feelings in me that you don't even fucking know.
Does everybody have a seat?
And in the merchants I have a lock.
This is look at is,
first of all,
he won the Olympics.
Come off my feet and they gave him a gold medal.
He won the Olympics of the world and he's standing in front of this gigantic
thing that's right out of a fucking movie,
like a Lex Luthor thing.
I find them to be browsing right there.
He's impressive.
He's impressive presence.
Okay.
These are the times we will all remember,
were you there?
What did you do?
I think you know that I am there for you.
And I do care so very,
very,
very much
so.
What do you say,
I'm going to clean this place up.
Oh,
she's talking about earth.
Are you going to go out there in the ocean
machine with Tom Dweller writes to Lrh l Ron Hubbard,
a man who was a terrible science fiction writer
who was quoted as saying that if you really want to control things,
start your own religion.
Okay,
so mister debunker,
Mr Debunker who me?
Yeah.
Does that mean,
is it true that Scientology was started as a bet to see who could do the best
cult?
That is the rumor,
but I think it's essentially the hearsay.
It's hearsay.
Well obviously he started it.
Obviously he created it.
I mean there's no,
there's no getting around that.
When you watch the bed,
if you want to know what the,
the actual history of Scientology is there look no further than the south park
episode because the South Park does it massive justice and they keep saying this
is the actual work.
Like they show you what they,
this is what they actually believe.
They also do that for Mormons.
And that's beautiful as well.
Um,
what I mean it's,
it's,
it's terrible science fiction.
It's just like battlefield,
earth.
It's like that movie that they made it the Travolta movie magically bad.
So good.
And it was magic leap.
I think you put like 80 million of his own money and to make it,
first of all,
how did you get 80000002nd wall?
That's a bad investment because the fucking movies dog shit,
it's,
but it's good.
It's no,
it's so bad.
It's good.
You need to just get really fucked up on an edible and sit through showgirls and
then when the edible really kicks into a strong peak and you're really worried
about the,
of your,
of
your,
uh,
all your friends and the earth itself,
that's when you put on battlefield or you know,
we're all going to be okay.
You're going to be fine by the time it's coming off,
you're like,
oh,
this is now I know where you're positivism comes from mockery.
God Damn.
Um,
we're out of time.
And that was awesome.
As usual.
You guys are the Shit we've got to do this together.
Idea was,
is this your idea?
Oh,
it was my idea.
Whoever's idea was,
it was brilliant.
It was such a fucking perfect idea.
Three favorite men's might.
Well,
you are,
you're my three favorite men.
How about that?
Um,
Shane Smith.
30.
Uh,
that's his Twitter.
Why Shane Smith?
30 my third because Shane Smith was gone.
But why 30 cause turn 30 just turned 30.
Okay.
And Eddie Wong is h.
U.
A.
N.
G.
Mr Eddie Huang.
And where can people sample?
You're fine dining in New York City to 38 east 14th street at Bauhaus Bauhaus.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm there at the end of January.
So,
uh,
I'll,
I'll be there,
man.
Fuck no,
it's your house.
I don't want,
I don't want to take it.
I just want to be a cast.
No responsibilities.
Come out.
I'm on vacation,
dude.
Love you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for that.
So,
such a good conversation.
So John Rogan,
Rogan,
Rogan nation.
Okay.
Um,
thanks everybody for tuning in.
Thanks to Lumosity Goto Lumosity.
Dot Com slash Joe and try that shit today son.
Get your dome and shape,
you know you need it.
Stop Front.
And we're also brought to you by stamps.com go to stamps.com and do everything
that you would do at the post office right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package the instant you need it.
Then the mail man picks it up.
It's over,
bitches you're game has done.
Go to stamps.com and use the offer code j r e for your $110 bonus offer.
We will also brought to you by on it.
That's o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain.
Use the code name,
Rogan and save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
Uh,
December 27th I will be at the Mirage in Las Vegas,
Nevada with ready greatest lineup of all time.
Joey motherfucking Diaz,
Brian motherfucking Cowan and Ari motherfucking should fear all in Vegas with
me.
One night,
December 27th,
we're trying to blow it out of the fucking back.
Uh,
and then of course,
New Year's Eve at the Melrose Improv in Hollywood.
I'm there with the lovely and talented Sam Tripoli and Super Twink,
Aka Tony Hinchcliffe.
That's his new stage name.
Uh,
and we'll be back tomorrow with,
uh,
the one and only Duncan Trussell.
Oh Shit.
It's a celebration.
Then Monday,
Joey Diaz,
next week,
Roseanne Barr as well.
We're not fucking around people.
Merry Christmas.
Happy New Year.
Go Fuck yourself
Mayans.
You were wrong again,
bitches wrong again.